[موسيقى]
لا عفويه
لازم تقول بدينا في البدايه لازم هذه اخر
عشر حلقات
مرتب معي من بعد نص ساعه بالضبط يسوي نفسه
ما درة بس الناس تحس
انها مقصوده انهم
شايفها يعني
في النهايه
زي اخر شيء تحطه تطبق الشروط والاحك ما حد
يقراها ايه فاحنا نر الكل ضيف
قبل قبل تسجيل بكم الوقت ما سجلنا معه وقت
ما نستق مع التسجيل نرسل الرابط يختار
المشروباته ويصير يحدد حتى الموعد التسجيل
بنفسه اذا ما كنا نستقنا معاه وهذا الموعد
هو مرتبط
بعدين التنبيهات على اللبس وما ادري وشو
واخر شيء اللي يعني ترى حنا نبدا اول ما
ندخل الاستديو وهذه خلاص كذا واضحه لها من
البدايه بس اتوقع انه ما تبان لهم ان اخر
شيء في ظننا خلص الرابط او الاستبيان فما
عاد تبان فبتحطها قدام بس اتوقع ترى
المفترض انه يكون عارف ان احنا نسجل يعني
اذا هو تابع اي حلقه من فنجان فهو مفترض
انه عارف انه بدينا تسجيل
نبدا بس هو على اي حاله يؤخذ على غفله
ويتوقع ان هذه السواليف بعدين تجي
السواليف ما قبل الحلقه اللي بيقول بدينا
يتواجد
بس بس يعني دائما يعني ما هو
يعني هي حلوه احيانا تطلع ان الضيف انه
مرتاح مره مدري كانك ماسك الوحيد
تفضحنا
يعني هي الهدف منها ان احنا نبدا الحلقه
باكثر اريحيه ممكنه فهو الهدف انه اذا
جاءت السواليف حلوه الانسان
طبيعي انه يتوتر قدام الكاميرا طبيعي
تبغى تقلل هذه الاضاءات والكاميرات
وحركتها وكل شيء رايحين
لكن
فليصير انك تبدا الحلقه اول ما يدخل ما
يدري يعني ما فجاه خلاص
بينتبه وهو لها عشرين دقيقه يسجل في خفت
توتر فهذا الهدف يعني
احسها احيانا يعني قد جت في بالي انها
تبان وكانها مبتذله مره اذا كان تعمدها
يعني قد قلت لك ايش رايك نصلحها
خلاص صارت يعني واضح بس وانا ادور في
تويتر كذا اتوقع يوميا مر مرتين مره تكتب
وادور فلاقي ناس كل حلقه فنجان انتظر هذه
البدينه فحس يعني صايره كذا صرت تقول ان
الضيوف ترسل لهم رابط
يختار وش يشرب ويختار درجه حراره الغرفه
يا رجل يختلف
فيه رابط قبل رابط بعد فكره الرابط اللي
قبلنا علشان ما يصير يعني هي المشكله يعني
اروح اسال الضفتني يناسبك بعدين اروح
استاذ عبد الرحمن يناسبك يمكن ما يناسب
اللي يناسبك
الزحمه هذه كلها تقدر تربطها بجدول عبد
الرحمن في جدول يعني
وتقدر خلاص يصير الضيف يختار اللي هو يبغى
ايام ونوافذ معينه ويختار من هالضعف فهي
مئه بالمئه انا ما عاد احتاج اقعد اراقب
جدول عبد الرحمن فاريح فهي اريح لهم واحس
انها جزء من تجربه المستخدم فهمت ان يعني
اوكي يعني انا احس انا عندي كذا فكره انك
كسرت الاحتكاك مع الناس احس انها احسن
فلما يتعامل معك المنتج اكثر احسن في هذا
التعامل البشري الانساني معه مدري ايش
الاخذ والرد حلو
يمكن تعطيه رابط اللي يدبر عمرك اخترت
تبغاه وما ادري وشو احس في هذا التقليل
تقليل جهد علي بس تقليل احتكاك بشري مو
يعني ما احس انه يخلق الفه فهمت طيب كيف
تعوضه
[ضحك]
افضل افضل الرابط اذا تبغى تتصل عليك اتصل
قلت حتى هو يعرف ايش الاشياء اللي يسويها
قبل يعني مثلا
نوع اللبس ولا بعض الاشياء اللي نحطها
يختار يعني اذا هو يحبك مثلا قهوه بارده
ولا حاره ولا يحب المويه ولا يعني طيب
الرابط يصير فيه يعني يعني ههه
لا ويعطيه انطباع اننا محترفين
رهيبين
[ضحك]
ان شاء الله
بس هذا تثبت ان هذا الشيء الحقيقي
بس كل مره قبل نبدا الحلقه الرجال يقول
والله هذا ضيف ما ارسلناه للرابط
بس خلاص صارت الحين كذا تلقائيا ويختار
تجي في رابط
هل يجي ما يدري عن اي شيء
ابدا يعني ابدا يعني في يعني في حلقه انه
كان يعني الضيف عن طريقي فاضطريت انه
النقاش يبدا معه واحس اني اقدر اشوفه يصير
في الحلقه
ثانيه انه
يقولون عندي ثنتين
كنت اقول لك ان الاولى
نظيف ما يصير عن طريقك فعشان اني انا ما
اتواصل
بس والثانيه ما تقعد
ابدا ابدا ان شاركه فكره الحلقه محاورها
الكبيره
وبس يعني فقط وبس يعني
كلهم
ثمانيه كلها دون استثناء ان ما شارك الضيف
اي سؤال
كثير في يعني الاشياء اللي تجي منها صحفيه
بس الثانيه اللي هي اهم بالنسبه لي
اذا صار محضر بيختلف
يعني بيختلف اسلوب وبيطلع عارف بالضبط ايش
يبغى يقول وتركي
فعارف تصير محاضرات يعني خلاص تصير
متخصص ممكن يحتاج انه يحضر معلومات مصادر
معينه
المهم لان البودكاست اصلا هو خطا يعني
عادي
يكون حاضر تمام هو مفترض انها سوالف
فنجان
مفترض انه سوالف يعني هي سالفه استراحه
اصلا في مشكله ترى احيانا على انه الناس
متضايقه وتلقاهم ثلاثه
صدق والله بس هي اللي ترسخ مخك تحس انه
الناس هي اللي تقول اوه بدينا تلقى الناس
مستانسه او انها ما طقت
هذا الفنجان وهذا عبد الرحمن مالح ههه
لا بس
ويبان مره لما يكون محضر يعني يحس انه
بالذات ممكن تقدر تلاحظها ببعض الضيوف
اللي تكررت لهم لقاءات صدق يعني عارف
الكفت فهو في اللقاء الاول يمكن ما كان ما
كان مره يدري وشو فنجان او انه يقول يعني
في جاهز بزياده تطلع اسوء وتدعي ما هي
يعني يبالنا
فاحيانا حتى في ضيوف بعد كان يعني عادي
انه يعطيك الاسئله فهمت فانت يعني
عادي يعطيك الاسئله مثل
عادي عامر عامر قحطاني بس عادي فهو هو
احيانا حلو احيانا لما احد يساعدك انه ترى
هذه نقاط عندي قصه حلوه فيها وكانت
ما تعرف خصوصا اذا كانت الحلقات هي سيره
ذاتيه في حلقات حلوه تكون سير ذاتيه مره
ممتازه والناس تحبها مره
[موسيقى]
في رابط تقييم بعد الحكومه
في ضيوف اعطوك تقييم نازل
حط حلقاتهم طيب
ترى التقييم مره كان يعني مره مهم بالنسبه
لنا نبغى نعرف
كيف
قبول الضيف للحلقه فهذه مناسبه لها هل في
مكان تطوير في مكان تحسين فكنا ننشرها قبل
بعد الحلقه نرسل لي اياها بعد ما تنشر
الحلقه اليوتيوب اليوتيوب
تجربه كامله الان قيمنا كيف التصوير كيف
الاستضافه كيف مكان
الاستديو ممكن كان تواصل معه كيف كان
الاعداد كيف كان
يعني التسويق للحلقه كيف كان التقديم
الشيخ تسويق الشيخ منتج طبعا ابراهيم
يسمعون يعني ابراهيم اللي يتكلم ويسال وما
ادري ليش
في فريق التسويق ثمانيه ايمن الحمادي منتج
فنجان
واترك القحطاني يعني قعدت كثير من الحلقات
فنجان مؤخرا
الان نقول ان الرابط
تصير احسن يعني
بعدين
ان اثر الحلقه على الضيف لانه بعد ما تنشر
الحركه الناس تحتفي فيه وكل شيء تمام فهو
يجاوب وفي نشوه
الحلقه كذا فتطلع كل شي بالنسبه لهم ممتاز
وقد نسيت التجربه يمكن احيانا احنا نسجل
اليوم نشربها ثلاث اسابيع يكون التجربه
الحقيقيه فصلنا نعطيه بعد ما يطلع اول ما
يطلع من الاستديو ظهر بعدها بساعه ساعتين
باقي فيه قهر
عشان كذا احس انها اصدق بس بشكل عام احس
انه مساله التقييم في مجتمعنا ما ادري اي
درجه هي حقيقيه حقيقي المجتمع احس ان احنا
نحب بعض واجد
يعني ههه فما ودهنه يعني يحس انه يعني
اكرمني مدري ايش قعدنا مع بعض يعني في نوع
من الاحترام فما ودك تعطيه مقبول ما ودك
تعطيها فما حد قال غير جيده او انها اللي
تحت مقبولاتي
ما وده يروح لذيك المنطقه
خطا عبد الرحمن ما كان حاضر الدهن واجد
حسينا تفرق بس احنا حنا
تعطي الضيف محاور ولا هو يتوقع شيء
بدي تعطيني شيء ثاني احسن ينقهر انا جيت
عشان الموضوع ابغى اتكلم فيه وانت جالس
تكلمني في سالفه ثانيه يعني دايما تاخذ
مكالمات مع الضيوف غالبا كذا
هذه المكالمه المفروض انها تعطيه فكره عن
الحلقه وين بتروح ولا انت تحاول تستكشف
الاعداد يعني هو احس على حسب في ضيوف
صراحه عارف وش نبغى منه اصلا
موجود او يكون لان احيانا يصير عندنا
الاسم بس ما نعرف ايش الموضوع المناسب له
فهمت وفي احيانا يكون عند الموضوع بس ما
نعرف مين الضيف والحين يجي هو معه يعني
قبل فهذا اروح علشان اعرف بس اكثر على
الموضوع يعني ماني متخص
فما ادري يعني
فحس انها فاحتاج اني اعرف عن موضوع اللي
هو وهو متخصص فيه كثير وفي مرات لما يكون
عندي الموضوع بس ما عندي الضيف فتجربه هل
هو يقدر يغطي الموضوع ذا فهمت الحين تلاقي
مثلا الناس متخصصين كذا مثلا تاريخ تاريخ
حديث في التاريخ المتخصص في التاريخ
الحديث ما تبغى تتكلم عن التاريخ الحديث
بالمجمل عندك فقره معينه او سالفه معينه
في التاريخ ودي تتكلم عنها فتجربه فيها
احيانا ما يبان لك من منتجات اللي موجوده
في الانترنت فتقول ودك تدق عليه تسمع منه
واحس ان هذه يعني مئه بالمئه تواصلي مع
الضيف او انه يكون له منتج موجود في
الانترنت يفرق في الاعداد مره تقرا اكتبهم
ولا تكشخ فيها عندنا بس مرات مره لا لا
صدق احس انها كثير من المرات اني اقراها
واطلع حتى الفهرس الفقرات ليش تضحك
يعني احيانا
يشيلها كذا
ويدور عنده مكتبه اللي شفت تراني شغال على
الاعداد وحاط زجاج بس شفاف يعني شوف تعال
عندي ههه
احس انها الضيف يشعر بقدر من الاحترام من
تقرا تقرا منتجاته وتجي جاهز له كفايه لما
يجي وانت ما تدري عنه شيء فيها عدم احترام
مره يعني بس يعني برضو انت لما يكلمه في
جزئيه
انه يعني احنا مثلا لما نبغى نتكلم عن
موضوع معين
عن حلقه نحتاج موضوع معين لهدف معين
وهو يجي ناصر الحلقات وكيف نختار المواضيع
هذه الثانيه اذا عندك الاعدادات على
السؤال
لا بس شاهد ان جزء من المكالمه انك احيانا
ان الضيف ما يكون
ما يبغى يمكن يتكلم عن الموضوع او هذا
الموضوع اللي انت تبغاه مهم ملم فيه مره
وهذا نادر لانك خلاص اتوقع انك انت عندك
الاسم وعندك الموضوع
بس احيانا مهم مره انك تبغى تعرف هل هو
يعرف تتكلم ولا لا
والقص هنا يعني كاريزما حاضره
يعني يقدر ياخذ يقدر يبسط المعلومات كذا
تتكلم في مواضيع معقده ما تقدر تشرحها
للناس او
يعني وما تخليها ممتعه احس انها فكره انه
الضيف ممتع وانت قاعد تكلمه يعني اقعد معك
ساعه انبسط انا احسها تفرق مره يعني انت
يعني بالنهايه المنتج او المعد هو الجمهور
الاول الحلقه فاذا انا انبسط احس الانسان
مره من الاول فاذا انا انبسطت
فهمت حاط نفسك
[ضحك]
يكون حضوره باهت
زين وقد يكون انه بس ظلمه يعني ظلمه
اللقاء هذاك كملنا كان طبيعي تخليك جامد
ومكثف وكذا وممكن يكون ما طلع الا دقيقه
او الاسئله ما كانت صح اصلا فهو كانت
اجوبته سطحيه لانك اللي سال اسئله ما ادري
ايش تبي فهو جلس يجاوب
احيانا تبغى تتاكد يعني انه على الاغلب
انه دائما تضيف افضل
[ضحك]
ليش لانها هو اللي يعني الاعداد من اسمنت
بتعد عبد الرحمن الى انه يسولف مع احد في
موضوع هموم متخصص فيه اصلا فانت قاعد عبد
الرحمن يسولف مع واحد في الفلسفه ولا في
الفكر زين وش يدريني انا بالفلسفه والفكر
بكره بتطلع واحد عن ما ادري عن الازياء
فالمعيار اللي اللي اظن انه حق الاعداد
الجيد صدق صدق انه يكون راضي يعني رضا صعب
شوي
لكن صدق يفرق لانه انت بتوترني بتقعدني مع
واحد فوق الساعتين ولا فوق الساعه
وبتخليني ما ادري كيف اسولف معه فاذا صار
الاعداد ناقص صار كثير من المعلومات ما في
هذه ما هو قاعد يضيف لعبد الرحمن اولا
فهذه يحس انه مشكله لانه اظن الضيف ما
يقيس عليه يضيفها على عبد الرحمن يقيس على
عبد الرحمن نفسه فهو عبد الرحمن انعكاس
العداد يعني فلسفه بس صدق صدق لانه هو
اللي بيجي يسال هذه اللي سواها الموعد
فاذا حاسس انها دايخه فغالبا عبد الرحمن
ما سالها بشكل جيد ان ما فهمها فا ما كان
جيد او اني اعطيتها اسئله دايخه ويحصل ان
نعطي اسئله دايخه
بالضبط
عبد الرحمن بس عاد
بس ليش الناس اظن انه تكشخ بالكتب في
المكتب كذا ليش الناس ما تشعر
بالاعداد هذا فيطلع عبد الرحمن بشكل عفوي
ولا تشعر انك قرات كتب ضخمه لان عبد
الرحمن ما يبان للناس انها مجهز يا اخي
انا احس ان هذه
احس ان لها لهج لها
كان العداد سيء وعادي يعني وارد انه يكون
فعلا قصرنا في حلقات طالع الاعدادات فطلع
يعني
او انه جزء من شكل الحلقات اصلا ان انا
بسالك اسئله بسيطه فقد يبدو السؤال اللي
انت ضنه غبي او انك تظنه دايخ ليش دعوه
تستعد السؤال قدام الناس
عشان تسال على السؤال ده زين ترى مصر
يشوفون حلقات مهم قامات ناس عاديين فانا
بس الناس العاديين هذولا
فهي واحده من ثنتين اما احنا ما كنا
جاهزين
هو انه كان كنا نسال السؤال بسيط اللي
المفترض انه يطلع
اللي في ذهن الناس فهمت علي في ظنون الناس
شفت الاعدادات القديمه كيف تشوف جوده
الاعداد كاعداد بذات شوف صدق
اكيد بتقول رائع واضح
يعني اذا كان الاعداد سيئه احيانا ممكن
انك انت تكون سيئه يعني
[ضحك]
بعاملك عبد الرحمن انه انت مو متخصص في كل
الحلقات فانا بعطيك الاعداد للشخص العادي
اللي بيدخل ويصير عندك تلحين يعني انا
بسوي جهدي في اني اجهزك مهارات الحوار
فهمت علي
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
يعني ممكن
المحاور مهم لا لا صدق والله هل حسيت
السؤال
[ضحك]
تحس انه في جزء من المعادله خربان يعني في
التحول من اعداد جيده الى احرار جيد
لان غير منطقي برضو يعني باخذ دور يعني
ههه
لا بس يعني كل الناس تقول انه
ما عمره اعد ولا حلقه
فيعني هل بيتفقون على
يعني
ما ادري احيانا تسوي اعداد جيد
ما عاد ادري احدد احيانا هل هي المشكله ان
انك ما تجهزت قبل او ما قعدنا كفايه قبل
او انه الضيف كان في باله تصور معين فهو
خرب عليك فانت ما قدرت انك تمشي بتسلسل
معينه وكان عندي يعني
وقت مره في الاعداد احس اني كذا مهيكله في
بالي تطلع كذا يطلع كذا
ما تطلع كذا
فاحيانا ما ادري هل هل لانك ما كنت جاهز
او لانه الضيف خبصتك
ودعك ورجعك فما قدرت انت تمشي بالتصور
اللي في بالي فهمت يعني اذا بعطي مثال اظن
انه أعطي مثال بس يا شباب
ابغى اقول من يوم يومي ههه
[ضحك]
باقي عندك كلمات ودك تقولها ههه
[موسيقى]
البناء اناقه التصميم ورفاهيه الخدمات مع
تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره ومستدامه
مع شركه صفاء للاستثمار المزيد في وصف
الحلقه
[موسيقى]
يعني حلقه فوزي فوزي البدوي احس انه كذا
يعني من ايام رمضان وانا قاعد اشوف مقاطع
وكده واتجهز لها ومدري ايش فحسيت كثير كذا
كان عندي تصور عن الحلقه بس وكذا في وسط
الحلقه انه احس الاعداد ما مش هزي مكان في
بالي
فهمت وتذكر كنت اقول لك
[ضحك]
معين كان يبغاها الضيف
بس شوف اظن انه يعني
فقره اننا يكون في في اكثر من جوله في
الاعداد بعدين ترجع تقول العب بس هذا ما
هو تمام مدري ايش تفرق مره مره تفرق في
اننا يعني نخرج بشيء مرضي عنها بشكل جيد
طيب كيف
يعني هو يختار او يعطي التعميد النهائي
للضيوف
وانت عاده ترفض كل اقتراحاتنا للضيوف بس
قبلها قبلها خليه يدافع عن نفسه خلاص
يدافع عن نفسه
[ضحك]
في حلقه لحالها على العداد باقي ما قيمني
واضح انك ما راح تتغير
[ضحك]
لا
الاعداء انا اعتقد ان الناس اصلا تخلط من
بين
يعني
ما ادري انا اعرف احس
انا اعتقد ان في سلوك عند الناس
ما اعرف منين يجيهم بس انه ينبسطوا لما
احد لما يمكن التلفزيون يمكن ما اعرف
والله يعني يمكن في العالم كله ما اعرف بس
انهم يحبوني اذا المقدم حشر يحسونه بطل
وانه كذا اخذ في زاويه وكذا وبدي هذاك
يتوتر الضيف
وممكن تسويها ما اعرف والله ممكن
خطا اذا صار هذا هو شكل الحوار الوحيد
الموجود والمقبول هذه المشكله
هذا واحد
فنجان ما له علاقه يعني انا اقول ما لي
علاقه اول شيء انه مبلقه
وهو حوار
وهذا يعني اذا ما هو هذا الحوار ما ادري
وش الحوار
او اذا ما هو هذا الحوار الرائع في انك
تقدر تخرج افضل ما عندي الضيف عاد هل افضل
ما عندي ضيف يتفق معي ولا يختلف معي هذا
الموضوع ثاني
مفترض انك انت تقدر تقيم اذا اللي قال
الضيف حلول ولا لا واذا هو يمشي مع
قناعاتك ولا لا يمشي مع الاشياء اللي انت
متفق معها ولا لا ابد يعني يعني انت تسمع
وقيم انت كلنا عقله في راسه يعني
فهذا برضو اثنين ثلاثه انه اذا انا والضيف
نمشي على نفس المستوى هذا يعني برضو يمكن
برضو جزء من اللي الناس اتوقعها من
البرامج المعروفه
الحين ثلاثه عشان
ثلاثه
على نفس
المستوى
بصير النقاش نخبوي وانا يعني اكثر شيء
يزعجني انه يصبح نخبور
بس فهي ليست نخبويه وانما انها تقدم محتوى
رائع جدا يفهم العامي
فهي ماده رائعه مفيده بسنها مفهومه للكل
كيف تخليها مفهوم الكل هذه مهاره ما يقدر
عليها الا عبد الرحمن
تقدر توصل معلوماتها المعقده جدا لما
تتكلم في الفلسفه ولا تتكلم في تاريخ
الاسلامي ولا تاريخ العربي ولا في التاريخ
المحلي لما تاخذ مواضيع في في الذكاء
الاصطناعي ولا في
يعني في الاقتصاد ولا في السياسه مواضيع
معقده بعضها علميه بحته يعني ما تقال الا
في الندوات اللي ما يتفرج الا 25 واحد
وتجيبها ويشوفها سبعه مليون يعني
يعني مهاره رائعه في قدرتك على تحويل
المحتوى هذا الى انك يعني يعني
رابعا انه يمدي احيانا انك تبين انك تعد
وانا ما ودي لانها تخرب 1 2 3
اللي هي انك يمديك تبين يعني يمديني اقول
والله في مقالتك اللي في عكاظ نشرتها في
عام 1421
قلت كذا وكذا وكذا
الناس تقول هذا واضح انه قافض ام الدنيا
اول ما اقول بس هذه المعلومه بس انه لما
انت تقولها شعوري طبعا يمكن واحد ثاني
يسويها ويقدر يتفاعل بس انا اتكلم كيف
اقدر اسوي حوار مع شخص يمكن في واحد عنده
مهارات تخلي حوار مع شخص
مو يحشر احس انه يعني بس يعجبني ترى انا
من الناس الرائعين اللي يعجبني من يوم كان
في الرياضيات
بس يختلف يعني ويقدر يطلع يمكن افضل او ما
عنده الضيف بس انه هذه اسلوبه يعني فكل من
قدره اسلوبه انه يسوي سالفه انا قدرتي
اصلا سالفه حلوه اني اخلي ضيفي مرتاح
واعتقد اني لو بديت انبش انه هو بيتوتر
وبيبدا كذا خلاص ترى حتى الشمال جزء منها
يعني الحين
تبغى أنا ههه
فجاه استوعب اللي ههه تبي تمسك
[ضحك]
يبدا يتوقعني اني بجيه من مكان لاني عارف
اني انا ماسك يعني اني باحث جدا في تاريخه
يعني فبغى يرتاح يسولف ما اقدر افهمه اجيب
لها هذي وتيجي امثله كثيره يعني مثلا لا
يمكنك مجارات اي ضيف لمده ساعتين تتكلم لا
يمكن لا يمكن لا يمكن
بس هي المهاره يعني التصميم الجيد لاي شيء
يعني المدينه اذا صارت مصممه بشكل رائع
انه ما في زحمه الناس تمشي في الشوارع
بدون ما تحس بالزحمه فما يشعرون في تصميم
رائع ليش
لان كل شيء صح وين تبدا المشكله اذا جئت
مشكله الناس بتتكلم عن سوء التصميم فالناس
ما تكتشف الشيء السيء الا لما تصير
المشكله بس الاصل تصميم جيد وكرسي جيد هو
مريح اول ما تقعد عليه
ومو لازم الناس تتكلم خلاص
فانا اعتقد فهو يرتاح ويمشي معاك ويتكلم
يعني مثلا في حلقه زي حلقه السودان غسان
مقطع احلى لناشرينه يعني احنا ننشره
ويتوقعوا الناس يعني هو مو مسيء ترى وانا
احدد كل الحلقات يعني بس اقدر اتحكم في كل
الحلقات واذا حسيت اني جبت العيد في مكان
ولا اني احس اني اهبل في مكان اقدر احذفها
يعني قبل لا تنشر فيعني ما نشرت الا اني
ادري انها هي مفترض انها تنشر هكذا يعني
ما في عيب ولا في خطا ما في خطا انك ما
تفهم ولا في خطر اي جزئيه انت ما فهمت
بس مثلا في غسان احنا نشرنا حقت
الانقلابات
هو يقول ما في انقلابات
والعالم كله يعرف فيه يمكن انا مدري كم
اكثر دوله عربيه فيها انقلاب
هذا ما يفهم انه ما في ينقلبات طيب هو
يعطيك سرديه مختلفه تبغى تتفق معها تتفق
معها يعني وش السرديه اللي موجوده فكيف
عرفتها
وبالتواريخ اذا انا ما اعرف لكن يعني ههه
ايوه امك اتفرج عليك كل اسبوع
يعني احيانا
احيانا احيانا يودها مؤشر خطير ترى ههه
حلقه الحزيمي
بعد ما وصلت 33 مليون صباح الخير
[ضحك]
وقفته ما عاد تجيني تنبيهات ولا احد طفاها
عليه نتيجه
او اليوتيوب فاهم ان اتجاه التنبيهات في
ما تضغط عليها
بس كل مره نروح نشغلها تنبيهات
عموما بس انت عندك مهاره يا اخي
احس المحاور
دائما عنده نزعه الحضور في الحلقه يعني
انا لازم اسال ولازم احجر احيانا ولازم
اكون موجود ولازم 20% من الحلقه انا اقعد
ابربر بس في حلقات يذهلني انه الضيف له 40
دقيقه يتكلم وطلع عن السؤال وراح يسولف
ويحط ويبني يسال كذا مواضيع فوق بعض
وما اسمعلك صوت
فمتى تعرف انه خلاص خلى يسولف انا
متى تحس انك لا احتاج ارجع الضيف يعني
احتاج ارجع اتحكم في الحلقه شويه ترى بس
ترى وتشوفه كنا يكتب
فانا ارفع رجلي عشان يتكي الايباد عليه
يعني بيقول لي ليش
عشان اقدر اقراهم وانا اشوف
فعشان كذا
فهو ما يشعر يعني
جلستي مهيله يعني والله بس عادي يعني ايش
تسوي المهم
ترى تويتر والله انه ماساه وانه خطا وجوده
في تاريخ البشريه لانه يطلع في الناس غصب
عنهم
فتلقى هذول البشر مو موجودين بحياتنا ترى
بس هو تدخل تويتر تصير انسان مختلف يجب
اني اهجم على اي احد
ههه
مشكله المهم فانا احط الايباد فلما انا
معي يوترني اني ما اقدر اطالع ترى
لما انا طالع الضيف يشعر اني اني طفشت من
كلامه وانا ما طفشت والله بس انا بس شفتك
فتحت موضوع معين لاني انا ما امشي حتى على
المحاور وترتيبها فهو لو دخل في مكان ثاني
اخليه يرتاح انا اقول له يبدا انت انطلق
انا دوري اني انا بوجهك انا بمشي معك يعني
يعني انت مش وانا بوجه السفينه وين ما
ابغاها
لكني ما اقدر اقول هذا محور سنه اتحدث عنه
بعد ساعه يعني اذا هو بدا من المحور
الاخير ما عندي مشكله
كذا فتفطر اني ابدا اقلب فيكون يعني احاول
الاعداد ميزه خمس صفحات احيانا الاستاذ
يعطيني 13 سنه كل ما زاد العداد عدد صفحات
كل ما عرفت انه سيء
جدا يعني فهو
فاحيانا تويتر لما ابغى انزل
فخاف انه يحس اني دائما تصير
فلما ادنك مو شعوريا يوقف يحس اني طفشت
انا ما طفشت تكمل والله
بسؤال لانك انت هسه تتكلم عن نقطه معينه
موجود استشهاد فيها هنا يعني اما ضدها او
انه يخليك تكمل فيها بس ابغى اجيبها
فنادرا انا تصميمي للورق باعداد ترى انه
يكون يعني لها تصميم معين ان يكون مدفون
في اليسار اقدر اكتب في اليمين الخط كبير
عشان اقدر بسرعه يعني كذا اقدر القى
الكلمه اللي انا ابغاها في اسرع وقت ممكن
فانا بس ثواني اللي طالع فيها العداد
فاحيانا اغلب الاسئله تكون يعني تحيانا
اتكلم
انا ما شفت الاعداد واذا كتبت احيانا اكتب
اني ما طالع اكتب وانا ما طالع والله بعد
مره ترجع ما اعرف شو كتبت
يعني وش الكلمه هذه
عشان اشوفه واحيانا عشان اقدر اطالع اخلي
عندكم مشكله شخصيه تويتر
يا ابدا من التعليقات الشعر
حلو كده يعني الناس تحس انه انا احس ان
شكلي
انا احس شكلي كذا يعجبني بس يعني في حلقات
تلقاها عمر عمار كاني ما ادري يعني مره
غلط بس لاني ما ادري
حلقه
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
ابتدائي
فكره غريب المهم انا احسه كذا يعجبني انا
هذا اللي يريحني انت يريح كذا صح عشان كذا
[ضحك]
هذا اللي يريحني الشمال ليش احنا نطلب
منهم عشان نعرف
يا محترم ومفترض انه ما يرسم صح في
الاستراحه يعني اللي يلبس الاستراحه ما في
يجي
يلبس استراحه شمال انا اتوقع في الاستراحه
ههه اللي يجي يصرفونا ههه
في لها نقطه يعني انها تخليك تشعر يعني
انا احاول انه في تصميم البرنامج كله انك
تشيل ما استطعت من احساس ان جالس يسجل
الرسميه هذه تحاول تشيلها تبغاه يرتاح
اكثر قدر ممكن بس هذا الهدف فاعتقد يعني
طبعا
انه بدون شماغ لان حتى لما تصير زي كذا
يعني انك تدري انك كذا انك رسمي فلما تلبس
شماغ انت ما انت انت
يا اخي
ايوه لما
يعني مدري اليوم
اخر حبه للي تحبه كذا ما
انت بنت انت مش انتم جوعان
يا اخي رهيب يا اخي كيف ان علامه تجاريه
تقدر تخلي كلمه
خلاص لما تفك ما احد يقول الكلام
[ضحك]
لعبه التسويق احيانا يعني انت تجيب ناس
يعني خلنا نقول قامات على قوله التركي في
المجتمع فتيجي تجلس الجلسه هذا
تجيب السؤال ايش الخطه في الترباع يعني لا
عنك احيانا رجلك كذا تصير يعني موجه
احيانا شكل الجلسه يصير انه ما هو ما ينبع
عن احترام لمقام الشخص الحين الشراب يعني
الناس يعني ههه
[موسيقى]
بس انها
[ضحك]
ارفع الكاميرا يلعب
من الناس اللي بشكل غريب يعني يوم دخلت
ثمانيه كذا بديت ابحث في التعليقات واتعمق
يركزون عليك احيانا بشكل يعني اكثر من
متى حسيت اشهر
كل شيء
لابس ايش كنت تقول
يا اخي اول شيء الناس ما ادري يعني اول
شيء رضا الناس
يعني بفضل الله ان الناس
يعني تقدرني وتحبني هذا اللي القاك في
الشارع يعني تقدير وحب رائع جدا احيانا
احيانا اتضايق لكن
ايش المشكله احيانا والله اني افهمهم
والله يعني ما بقول خطا بس اني افهمهم بس
انها تصير
تصير في ذاتها
خطا يعني خطا يعني كذا مره كنت ماشي هنا
والله كنت مع اخواني واخذت ايس كريم رائع
اخذتها ايس كريم وانا طالع
ببرر له بس ان الفعل لنفسها كنت مزعجه
بالنسبه لي فانا واخواني جلسين نمشي شو
يقول لي هاي هاي يعني
[ضحك]
اطالع ما طالع بس انا الحين الشعور انه
واحد درس معي في الثانوي يعني قديم من
زمان وانه او انك صرت مشهور
يعني
كذا قلت
[ضحك]
يعني واحد من اخوياي اللي في الثانوي يمكن
المتوسط يعني واضح انه مره يمون بزياده
يعني
وبروح بقول له يعني
وقرب انا بقرب واعرفه
قلتها تعرفني اعرفك انا
اعرفك يا اخي ليش الاسلوب كذا
اتعشى
قهرني يا الله
انسان يعني طيب
مشكلتك طيب والله ما كنت انا وامي واخواتي
واخوي
هذيك هذيك ما انساها ويجي
هلا بالخوي طالع فيه
شفتك في الشارقه اوكي يعطيك العافيه
طيب يقول ماني خلنا نتصور
وانا يعني
أنا كذا لابس شماغ ترى عيدك يا الله
فكذا يعطيك العافيه والله شفتك والله
ممتاز شكرا
المهم
مستحي لاني بعطيك تبريد حقهم
فاستحي
كده طالع
مع اهلي وش تتصور يعني
الاهل موجودين قال ما في مشكله اهلي
بايدينا مالك
ابعدينا
تخاف العائلتين ما راح يتعرفون والله ههه
انهم كلهم كانهم يعرفوني زين
يعرفونك يسمعونك طول الوقت فهو عنده علاقه
معاك انا ما هي موجوده احيانا بعضهم يقول
ترى انا اعرف كيف تعرفني واحس انك صديقي
انا انت اول مره تشوفني بس يعطيك العافيه
شكرا لك وزي كذا بس فاحيانا هو يحس انك
يعني يعرف متى يعني
تعرف مدري ايش تقول يعرف مدري كيف يعرف
انك تتضايق وانت السالفه يعني
صديقك وانا اول مره اشوفك
في الشعور يصير متلخبط او زي يمكن
السناب ولا تيك توك لما هو ينكت ويلعب اذا
كان محتواه وبعدين يجون ينكتون معاه فجاه
ترى انا بس اسوي المحتوى هناك
يعني مو بس يمكن بودكاست تحديدا بس واحده
من مشاكل الانترنت انك انت ممكن تعرف واحد
لك عشر سنين وتفاصيل حياته وتخرج من
الجامعه ومتى تزوج ومتجاه ولد وايش يسوي
في كل يوم وهو ما يدري انك موجود اصلا
تخوف اللي
فنفس الفكره في البودكاست اكثر لانها
ساعات حتى طويله فانت تعرف تفاصيل اني انا
قد سويت كذا وانا قلت كذا وانا البس الثوب
الفلاني وانا اطلع الاجلس الجلسه مدري ايش
قديم في المحتوى قديم بالمحتوى
[ضحك]
ترى اشتكى من ذا الشيء انها مشكله عند
المشاهير ان كنت لما تقرا روايته تحس انها
خويك
فما بالك انه عنده عشر روايات فمن جد
يتضايق من شعور الناس انه كلهم يبغون يصير
اصدقاء يقولون يا جماعه الخير انا ما عندي
وقت انك تكونون اصحابي
فخلوني
جمهور عقال يعني ههه
جيد لا اكون جيد في التواصل
تفضح شخصيتك الجديده يعني يصير يصيدونك
ترى في في واحد هو كاتب عندك كتب
وعنده يقول اني اقدر اعرف حقن كتاب
من طريقه هذي احس انه خويي اعرف انه
يشعر انه خويي
الكتاب يجي هلا مرحبا اهلا استاذي
يختلف بس يعني ذاك اليوم
ما ادري
اليوم يوم الجمعه الجمعه الصباح
وهذا اللي على على
تبغى اكون صديقكم كلكم
اتصال غريب يعني
فقلت يعني سبع الصباح يعني ما طلبت لا من
جاهز ولا ما طلبت يعني
اذا يعني الشكل مثالي انك اذا تبغى شيء
انك ترسل رساله
بعدها تتصل ما في مشكله بس اني ابغى اعرف
من انت يعني يمكن ما
بردك
صدق والله يعني مره يقرني بيكتب السلام
عليكم
وعليكم السلام
[ضحك]
صباح الجمعه مفترض انه ما عمر احد دق عليه
صراحه احس حتى لو تبغى تفطر صباح الجمعه
ههه
يعني ما احد ما احد بالله ما قد جاني
اتصال اسبوع الواحد ينام
الناس الناس غريبه والله
بس نرسلها الرابط
بس انت عموما ما تتضايق لما الناس كذا تجي
يعني احس ما قد طلعت معك لكن
بعضهم يصور بعضهم بس بيسلم بعضهم
يعني اكيد اني شخصيتي يعني اكيد انه هذا
من محبه بس انا شخصيتي اني حياوي بس هذا
ولا يعني
[ضحك]
مثلا خصوص يقول لك يعني
ههه
[ضحك]
يعني
يقول لك عادي بفلتر
اما توصل
فهو يحب فلتر فتطلع قلوب فقره
ههه
ترى استحي اني ما اقول لا
تبغى كلهم ماتوصل عاد
الخاتم والله اني صرحت
لا لا قال محمد الحاج يقول اكرم ما اكره
فيك الخاتم
اوكي
تكلمت عنها من شركه اتكلمت
اللي يبغى يجي يدفع تكلمنا عنه اوكي سابقه
موجوده في النشره ههه
كثر ههه يا اخي كنت ابغى اسوق للنشره
بطريق
محمد كنت ابغى اعلن ان الناس التحدي بيني
وبينه زين كنت بقول يعني في واحد متحدين
اني اجيب عشرين ثلاثين الف خلال شهرين
[ضحك]
انه يصير انه تجي اشتراكات بغير فعاله
الدعم بس
[ضحك]
انا اقول ان نشره اي قلت والله اني قلت له
انا ما قهرني لان كل ما قلت لاحد في
الفريق ان نشرت فنجان اعلى نشره موجوده في
ثمانيه يمكن طبيعي يعني
فهو قال والله مستحيل اصلا
تتجاوزها يوم قال وجهها تعبيرة
يستحقر
ضغط ههه
فهل هذا السالفه الحين قاعد تحاول تعلم
الناس على التحدي بشكل غير مباشر
لان يا اخي
نضيف مقاله الروائي
عادي
ههه
سوى هذاك الياباني البنيويورك
انا لازم ابدا انتبه ما اطلع بقميص مثلا
سؤالك طيب كل اسئلتي طيبه
لا قبل الحسين
هذه كانت الكذا المرحله قبل
الحسيمي
يعني
بس يعرف وين اروح في اماكن
يعني اذا رحت مقهى اتمنى نحب اني اشتغل
المقاهي والله بس انا ما صرت اقدر
ما احب الاماكن اللي انا اكون في ناس
تعرفينه بس عموما كانت المقاهي المختصه
هذه اماكن على الارجح من الناس
بس ما بعدها خلاص
[ضحك]
انتشرت عند نطاق اخر مختلف تماما وفي ناس
يعني متى اعرفه
سالني يا اخي انا شايفك وين ما اعرف
بس اذا انت اللي في التيك توك فتجيني هذي
ترى اعرف ان الحزيمي
تيك توك يا اخي
يعني احس اني اخاف اقول ايه ويطلع واحد
ثاني
ابو سعد
صدق متى حسيت انك مشهور لما جلست بعد
الفطور في رمضان فتحت التلفزيون لقيت واحد
قاعد يقلدك
[ضحك]
عرفت بدات تجيني
انه في تقليد وكده يعني عرفت
هو كل سنه ترى على السنه
يكون شغال فاعرفه يعني انا في البرنامج
عرفت
المهم
ما عجبتني والله بس يعني
يعني في شخص انت يعني ما عندي مشكله
يعني مره سهل انك طقطق علي مره سهل
بس هو مقدم برنامج واضح انه ما يدري وشو
فنجان يعني اسف يعني في حلقات
يضبط تقريبا
بس يعني مثلا يوم مقلد مدافر يعني عاد ما
ادري اذا عجبته ولا لا بس انه جاب محمد
عبده ومديفر والبرنامج ديوان يعني مو واضح
لانه كله يعني
ما قصر يعني بس مجهود اكثر من كذا
هذه الا في حلقه حمزه نمره الله يهدي قلبه
يعني
ترى
بعد المجهود الحين
[ضحك]
لا لا يعني
هو جاب الخاتم جاب بعض الاشياء بس يعني ما
فهمت يعني اثنين زائد يتضاربون
اصلاح زوجين مدري شو برنامج
ما اقول اوف يعني
تقييم
يعني ما اقول اوف ما هو تقديمي يعني في 60
مليون لازمه يمديه
ينكت كذا ولو نكت زين والله كنت ابغى
اتفاعل معها فكنت بتفاعل اصلا واقول ان ما
اعجبني فحسيت انه بيحسوني
عنده محتوى كويس يعني يقدر والله سهل
عجيب عجيب اها
احس مقياس الشهره انا بالنسبه لي انك تصير
ميمة اتوقع اول وحده يعني بجهتين انت مين
وفنجان فالناس تحط ضيف كذا الغلاف حق
فنجانه جوني سبرانو
تحديات اداره النفايات ههه
والله ههه
الحمد لله يعني في اتوقع اول واحده يمكن
كانت ينزلها رائده اعمال
البريد السعودي
[ضحك]
والله
لما يعني مثلا
يوم تعشينا
فكان في المطعم
اللي تشتغل
فطلعنا
من كانت تقول ان سمعت حلقه
وحلقه المطاعم
مشكله المطاعم القحطاني
فاثرت في حياتها الحلقه وغيرت من
سلوكها يعني صارت عندها معلومات جديده
صارت الحين مديره المطعم ترققت بسبب
الحلقه اوف او الحلقه ما طولت
لما تشوف هذا الاثر انا مره هذا اللي
يهمني
مره مره مهم لان هذا الهدف اللي جاء من
اجله كل شيء يعني الاثر فلما تشوفه مثلا
هنا لما تشوفها حتى على الضيوف لما تشوف
الاثر يعني مستمعين يعني لما واحد يقول
اني غيرت تخصصي او اني
بديت اسوي شيء معين جديد او علاقتي صارت
احسن يعني لما نكثر حلقات مثلا الصحه
النفسيه وفجاه الناس يعني يهتمون بالصحه
النفس هذه هي اللي اذا تاثرت حياه الناس
بشكل ايجابي يعني ولا احلى ولا اجمل يعني
هذا
تاثيرها على الضيوف ولا ما تنبسط عليها
مره
يعطوني نسبه
[ضحك]
يعني في ناس اتوقع انها فرقت معهم حتى
تجاريا
يعني ما شاء الله الحمد لله يعني تاثير
فنجان انا اعرف يعني يقينا ان
وفي ثمانيه اجمالا ترى اي برنامج برامج
ثمانيه تاثيره اعلى من اي قناه اخرى نقطه
نقلب الصفحه
فنجان فنجان
تاثير عالي جدا
ومره مهم يعني مثلا زي حلقه
المطاعم
كذا يعني الحلقه بس طرف سالفه ان المطعم
الحين بتزيد المبيعات
هم يدرون يعني
المبيعات عنده 60% من ذاك الوقت الى اليوم
ما توقفت
راحت
فيصل سعود فيصل سعودي ما شاء الله يعني
كتب نفذت من الاسواق والله هبه حريري انا
اتذكر يوم كان عندها طبع الاولى من كتابها
انبسط ترى كنت اتابع المتجر يعني مره افرح
والله يعني
تنفذ
فهذا الاثر يا الله يعني ما مثل بس يعني
ففي اثر على الجمهور
في هنا شيء
مره هذا اللي يهمني يعني صدق يعني اللي هو
الاثر اللي يقع عليهم
ايجابا
ولذا اصلا احنا نمنع يعني مره وحسابي
الحمد لله يعني نقدر نكسب منها
بس هذا اللي يخلينا كله حقيقي حقيقي ان
المحتوى نصنع لانه نبغى نسوي اذل محتوى
فيبان يعني هي اشياء لا تشترى
صدق الله يعني هي شعور هي روح تكون موجوده
ما تدري ليش يعني
فانت حقيقه فالناس يصلهم مثلا نمنع
الاعلانات يعني لا يدفع احد ريال في
ثمانيه كله عشان يطلع محتوى نقطه نهايه
الصبر يبغى يعلن اعلان واضح ان اعلان ما
له علاقه بس المحتوى ما في احد يدفع
اعلان كذا يدخل في المحتوى يعني ما يجي
ضيف للمدافع الفلوس كل برامج اجتماعيه ابد
كلها يعني ممكن احيانا تضيفكم ممتاز
فيقول انا بدفع لك وهو ممتاز فنقول لا
تدفع لي بس
ممنوع الدفع نهائيا وهذه خلي الناس تكفيك
هي اشياء كذا الناس ليش تثق فيك تثق ان
الضيف اللي جاك حقيقي ان الكلام حقيقي ان
كل شيء حقيقي يعني ممكن يكون كذاب ممكن
يكون صادق
تشعر فيه بس انها تثق في العلامه انها
تطلع الناس بناء على الموضوع حقهم
يقول بعد سنه بس هذه الحلقه اللي وصلت
الملايين الناس تجاوزت نصف مليون مشاهده
على النص اليوتيوب
ساخبركم ببعض ما حدث بعدها يبشركم يعني
واضح ان في اشياء
ما شاء الله يقول القضايا المطروحه في
الامن اللساني والاستثمار اللغوي وتفعيل
السياسه اللغويه وضبط دعم اللهجه السعوديه
قوه ناعمه هو هاجس وزاره ثقافه من قبل ومن
بعد
لا تقلل ابدا من صدمها تطرح طالما كنت
مؤمن بالقضيه تشرفت بتكليفي ضمن مشروع ضخم
وعالمين زار الثقافه يتوافق تماما مع دعم
ملف العربيه هو ناعمه وسفيره غير مؤدرجه
لصوره السعوديه خارجيا وفي دهاليزكو
وانهينا معظم المشروع بطريقه علميه تتوافق
مع الاطار الاوروبي
المشتركم
[ضحك]
مره يعني شفت زي كذا احس انه ولا لما حتى
محتوى ثمانيه انه يصل يعني احنا
عرب من كل مكان
بس بس يعني بطبيعه الحال ما انا في الرياض
وكل شيء
لما يصير فيه ناس تهتم للمحتوى وتشوف انه
يعني تغير نظره الناس عن صوره نمطيه
مشكلينها برضو احس اني انبسط منها بس احنا
ما يعني ما نستهدف هذا الشيء اي بس اقصد
انه ثمانيه اليوم السعوديه ما تشكل اقل من
النص صح اه تفاجات مره مره مره مره منه
يعني مره رهيب بس تفاجات يعني ان السعوديه
40% ان السعوديين يتابعون ثمانيه هم فقط
40% من متابعي من جمهوره اليوم من جمهور
اليوم يعني مين غير السعوديين يتابع يعني
في عندك المغرب العربي
يشكل برضو يمكن 30% طبعا تجيك المغرب
الجزائر تونس
كمان فرنسا اللي ما اتوقع فرنسيين مره
يحبون واضح انهم في عرب المغرب العربي في
فرنسا لانه فرنسا اربعه في المئه
فيعني ما يشكل كتله من كتلاتين في المئه
من المغرب العربي في عندك مصر عندك الكويت
عندك الامارات عموما انه فيه هذا الخليط
مره رائع يعني شيء يمكننا نقول شيء ما كنا
يعني اشتغلت عليه في التسويق
لا لا بس يعني عضوي
بس يعني اشوف في بعض الحلقات ولا ادري ايش
السبب صدق يعني خطط
روزه الوضع سهل ههه
يا شباب
يعني في حلقات الاحظ انها مترجمه
بالانجليزي
الترجمه ما اتوقع مو بكل البرامج مترجمه
هذا اول شيء يعني اتوقع فنجان ويمكن
برنامجين ثانيه في حلقات مهمه من سقراط
رئيس
[ضحك]
تفضل يعني
كلها نفس البرنامج
يسولف مع اصحاب الاعمال
يستهدف اصحاب او او مناصب الحكوميه
المتعلقه بالرؤيه او الضيوف اللي هم
يشوفون
الجميع ههه
[ضحك]
بس فنجان مربع يعني ايش الفرق
ما فرق كبير لانه يفرق ترى نفس الضيف لو
طلع ان في مثلا زي ما يفرق معي حتى عمر
فمثلا محمد الجابر طلع في حلقه في سقراط
طلع في حلقه فنجان
تختلف تماما تختلف تختلف بناء على رغبه
الضيف عفوا على رغبه المضيف اللي يسال
المحاور في كيف تطلع الحلقه اصلا فتختلف
الحلقتين تماما يعني ونفس الشيء يصير مع
حاتم يعني
فاول شيء يختلف يختلف نوع لانه هموم حاتم
همومي او اسئلته واهتماماتي تقتنع
اهتماماتي فتصلح القتال مختلفتين هم
جمهورين مختلفه وكل ما وصلنا للناس كل ما
زدنا المحتوى المهم
كل ما حققنا الهدف الاساسي
انت الحين اذا قلنا فنجان هو انعكاس
الاهتمامات عبد الرحمن فهل اذا موضوع او
ضعف انت ما تحبه
حلو هل ممكن ان جاء ايمن اذكر اول اسبوع
جاي جاي
أنا لانه هو يوم
متحمس ابقترح ضيف
وايمن عطاني وضعيه يكلم عبد الرحمن اللي
ما بيدخل فيها ههه هي هذه تصريفتي
وتصريفها ايه فلما رحت جيت قلت لك انا هذا
الشخص ما ابغى بغض النظر عن الموضوع بغض
النظر عنده محتوى كويس ولا لا شخص ما ابغى
شخص
مو كذا يعني احاول ما استطعت يعني في ناس
ما احبهم يعني مو كل الضيوف اللي استضيفهم
احبهم
ما العلاقه الحب والكره يعني احيانا
ايه لا والله صدق مره احرس انه ما العلاقه
المشاعر الشخصيه تجاه الضيف اني ما لها
علاقه بس ما تحس ان هذه اذا احنا نعرف
فنجان قاعده ابين صديقين على فنجان قهوه
فنجان قهوه انها تصعب عليك
ماني دخلت
عندي استقامه منهم 300 كلهم
اثنين قاعدين مع بعض يشربون فنجان قهوه
فما تحس انها حبك كرهك لو يؤثر
ممكن ممكن ابغى اكون يعني ودي ودي يعني
هذا الطموح فاحيانا انا احارب نفسي
نسوي هذه الحلقه زي مثلا واحد يبغى يتعلم
التعلم ما هو شيء انت تحبه نفسك على انك
تتعلم فانا اخذه من هذه المنطلق اني ودي
فنجان هو مكان انك تسمع اراء وافكار
وتجارب مختلفه
يعجبك ما يعجبك الموضوع ثاني موضوع ثاني
ابد يعني انت تخلي الارات تكون موجوده خلي
المكان هذا نقاشي خليك تسمع افكار ونقاشات
هذا اللي يحرك عقول الناس ويخليهم افضل
فانا اذا قدرت اني اسويها هذه احس انه مره
مثالي
فيختلف بالله
لو تخلون ابراهيم احسن من عبد الرحمن يقدم
ثاني احس انه احباط رسميه توهم بكره
جايبين مدير تسويق جديد ههه يعطيك العافيه
يا ابراهيم
صوره الغلاف
[ضحك]
ما اختلف لا لا يعني يختلف في الضيوف اللي
يختلف معهم يعني قلبا وقالبا يعني بعطيك
مثال قاعد يصير
هل عنده فكره يبغى يقوله هل عنده تجربه
اذا عنده واحده منها خليه يقولها وخلي
الناس تحكم يعني كل الناس بتصدق كل شيء اي
احد يقوله المهم بهذه السداد
الحين الحين اليومين هذه صاير كذا نقاش
على معجون
فان استضاف واحد
اتوقع روبرت كندي فكان يتكلم عن اللقاحات
وان اللقاح اصلا كذبه وان مدري ايش وجاء
دكتور رد عليه قال له اذا فيك خير تعال
تناظرون
اللقاحات الارض المسطحه
المواضيع اللي
يعني مواضيع ماهب في نسبه كبيره في
الانترنت تؤمن بهذه الاشياء وتخوف يعني كل
ما تتعمق في تيك توك وانا ما انصح يتعمق
تيك توك
بس تكتشف انه في الاف مؤلفه تدخل اليوتيوب
في مقاطع مئات الالاف وناس تنظر وعندها
هذه النظريه في ناس تربطها بالدين موضوع
اللقاح يعني احنا طالعين من كورونا كان
فعلا موضوع في ناس الى الحين مؤمن انه
اللقاح هذه الاشياء ليش فنجان ما جاء يعني
بالنظريه العكس لا مو النظريه العكس قد
انه انت لانك مؤمن ان الارض كرويه فخلاص
ولا مؤمن ان اللقاح كويس على حسب والله
احيانا يعني شوف يعني من ناحيه المبدا انا
اعتقد ان ما عندي باشكال لو نتكلم بس اني
ما اتوقع ان في احد عنده
راي جيد في فكره تسطيح جمهور مسطحه الحين
فبيبدا يطلبون اني اصير من ناحيه ما عندي
مشكله يعني علوم الطاقه زين
هذه محور عجب بس ما عندي مشكله
فعادي يعني المجال يعني
ما عندي مشكله ودي افهم يعني
بسمع منك يعني قد سمعت كثير بس يعني ما
انا مره مره غير مؤمن اطلاقا يعني ولا
يمكنك اقناعي يعني مره هنا مسكره احس بس
ما عندي مشكله ودي يعني يمكن يمكن في فكره
ما اعرف والله تحس انه هذا عيب عليك انت
يعني احس البودكاست يعطي
سلطه خلنا نقول حتى طلعت في تيك توك ان
الناس تحط مايك وسماعات ويتكلم ما يناظر
في الكاميرا شفته عشان بس اطلع كميه رهيب
فالناس تفترض ان كل شيء قال في بودكاست صح
فلما تجيب واحد مثلا في علوم الطاقه
وتخليه ساعتين يسولف على العالم في ناس
ممكن تسمع الهواء يعني ما تحس انها كذا
يعني افهمك والله يعني اني اروح انا احط
افكاري وارائي في البرنامج بس ما ودي بس
هذه فكرتي ان ما ودينا يعني ودي
بما استطعنا من الحريه
في اختيار الضيوف وفي الافكار اللي تقدر
تطرحها بس عادي انه يجي يروج شيء انا مع
هذه يعني وش الخطا خطا عندك صح عندي صح
عندي خطا عندك يعني ما في وشو الحقيقه
المطلقه اللي انت ما اعرف اللي تقول ان
هذه خطا
بس الفكره هي على اي اساس بتحدد ان هذه
الفكره دائم يصير فما قد يصير
يعني نقاشات لا تنتهي
هدي النفوس طبعا
برنامج ههه
على فكره ههه
انا فكرتي سؤالي هو وش الفكره اللي يعني
ما فتحت الرابط
التواصل الشخصي لازم ههه
الفكره اللي اللي قابله يعني وش وش معيار
الفكره اللي تطلع واللي ما تطلع فاذا انا
صار عندي انه كل شيء كل الافكار يا قابله
للنقاش
ايش اللي معدناقشه يعني وش وش معياري في
ان هذه فكره صالحه للنقاش وهذه فكره غير
صالح النقاش يعني انا اظنه
اذا انت جبت لي فكره ما تحترم عقد المشاهد
انا ما اؤمن بعلوم الطاقه تمام
مشكله لما تضمن
انا ما اؤمن فيها وانا اظن انها عدم
احترام لعقول الناس اننا نقدم احد يتكلمون
عن انا اظن هذه واظن ان هذه لها اثر على
انها كيف الناس يتعاطون مع فنجان وكيف انه
يثقون بفنجان مهما حاولت عبد الرحمن انك
تقول انه فنجان هو قعده بين اثنين يشربون
بنفس الوقت الناس تاخذه حراك ثقافي على
التعبيرك في النشره
فمهما حاولت ما تقدر تخليه هي قاعده بين
اثنين بس مريحه يسولفون براحتهم الناس
ياخذونك ويستعملون هذه الاشياء في تغيير
حياته في تغيير افكاره في تغيير قناعاتهم
فمهم منطقي ان كل الافكار هي الافكار
قابله للنقاش
كل الافكار قبل النقاش يعني شلون يعني
مثلا عندك
هنا مثال
يعني هو واحد من الاشهر في العالم
يعني الناس اللي في ضد اللقاح كثير
وامريكا من النسب اللي عندهم لقاحات عاليه
عادي مقتنع باللقاح ومقتنع باللقاح واللي
مو مقتنع باللقاحهم وغير مقتنع الالقاح
واصلا هذا الموضوع اصلا حتى يعني اللي
كانت تقول الوزارات ولا يعني انا مع الصحه
العامه فما عندي مشكله يعني
بتحرج تدخل فيها لانك ما ودك تاثر بهذا
الاثر السلبي لغرض النقاش
بس انه احيانا ان في اشياء
للنقاش يعني
ما يفرق احس انه بيزيد من يعني انت بتجيب
هذا بتجيب هذا
الناس اسمه وهي تقدر يعني وتقرر يعني فما
اعتقد اني لو
يعني بس يعني
انت سمعت حلقات تلقاها عن مواضيع انت
تختلف معك
وبالضروره انك فجاه تكون
اعقل من الناس وانه البقيه هذول هم ناس ما
يفهمون انا ابي اعلمكم وش اللي انا بسمح
لكم
انا اقول لكم وش الصح اللي تسمعونه ايش
الخطا اللي ما تسمعونه بس ما بس تواك انت
تمارس الاسريه بالضروره شلون انا قاعد
تمارس يا اخي مدير المعضلات الاخلاقيه
نقاش
[ضحك]
ههه
يعني انت تمارسها شلون يعني يوم تقول مثلا
انك
ما راح تجيب حقين اللي ضد اللقاح لان هذا
بياثر على الصحه العامه تهمك ما تبغى تخلق
اثر سلبي على الصحه العامه فد مارست
الاستاديه للضروره
وحتى انت لما شغلتين يعني اول شيء انها
فيها يعني ممكن يعني لحد ما سنها في وضع
حرج والناس يعني في حجر وفي ازمه فانت ما
تعيش وضع طبيعي في الاوضاع غير الطبيعيه
تحدث اشياء غير طبيعيه
اثر سلبي غيرك ما يشوفها اثر سلبي يعني
انا باخذ لقاح بعدين خليني عقيم بعدين
خليني انجب عضلات القلب مدري ايش يصير
فيها فانت قاعد انت اللي تحدد من الاثر
السلبي وانت بنفس يعني انت قاعد تحدده
اصلا بدون ما تشعر أنتحدثته فانا هذا اللي
اقصده انه خليه خلينا اللي يقول عقيم وهذا
انك ما بتجيب اصلا
لانه ما يفهم بالضبط
المسطحه ان الوصول البشر للقمر الاشياء
اللي فيه كذا وفي كذا يعني في ناس اثرها
ههه
كاسب الجمهور حقهم ههه
زين الحقيقه مشكلتي مسطحه قصتك ههه
ههه فانا احس ان هذا الاثر السلبي ما تقدر
تقيسه فانا هذا اللي اقصد باحترام باحترام
عقول الناس فهمت علي يعني
وتدوير الارض اصلا او كرويتها انها مثبته
علميه فاي شيء مثبت علميا يمكن خلاص نقدر
نقول هذا مثبت علميا فانا عندي احد يحدد
ايش الصح والخطا فيها بس الاشياء اللي ما
فيها صح وخطا يعني ممكن تكون الصق بالامور
الفكريه اكثر طيب هل ممكن انك تجيب احد
عشان توري الناس قديش هو خطا فانا بجيب لك
واحد اللقاحات يمكن عشان يوريك انه ممكن
اقولها الناس كلها ناقص على بعض ههه
مثلا مناظرات ثمانيه حقها ورح جيب لي تبيه
زي كذا يعني خلاص
فنجان طبيعته ما تسمع طيب ليش انت ما تسوي
هذه رغم فنجان ترى يعني على التعريه ممكن
تكون ايجابيه فترى هو يعري معظم الضيوف
معنى الفكري انت تعرفه تقدر تفهم
سواء كانت سلبيه ولا ايجابيه تقدر تفهم
بشكل كبير كيف يفكر الشيخ سالم بافضل
طريقه ممكن ترى افضل طريقه لانها احسن
طريقه عندي ترى يمكن يطلع نفسه افضل طريقه
ممكنه يكون اسوا انسان موجود يعني لان طلع
نفسه صار سيء قدام الناس من افكار الهدف
مو انه تمسك عليه
مو كنت حشرته بزاويه لان يقول هذا قل
فكرتك السيئه هذه قلها بافضل طريقه انت
ترتضيها
وما بين انك تتحدى فكرتها
تفيد تحديات احيانا
انك تخليه احيانا انك تعدل الفكره تخليه
يطلع يشرح افضل
[موسيقى]
هل الغرض انك تبيه ينحرج متحمر خدوده انه
يبدا ما يعرف يرد ولا انت تبغاه لا بس انه
فكرته تزيد وضوح
يفرق الهدف احس انه واضح طيب عشان نطلع
نطلع ايمن من مشكله المعضلات الاخلاقيه
شوي تخليه يهدا في ضيوف يعني شفت يصير خير
صح حق عبد الله حسين في اول حلقه معناه
حمدان
في يومين جابت مليون الظاهر
في ضيوف مثل نايف اتوقع افترض انه اسمه
تكرر كثير الناس تجيبوا نايف حمدان
انا كذا حطيت نايف مثال اقدر اقول لك احمد
الشقيري عبد الله مديفر
سميه الناصر
احمد الغندور محمد اللي هو الدحيح
على طول
كذا في اسماء تتكررت اتوقع كثير حتى لو
انت ما انتبه في ثمانيه تبحث تويتر تلقى
الناس تتكلم بس واضح انكم كذا
يعني مثلا احمد شقيري اقدر اعطيك كل ضيف
يمكن
اللي تبغى يعني
[ضحك]
سبقني
مو اكثر
على الضيوف الحين اوه لا
مجال المختلف يعني ترى في ناس تحس
بودكاستاسه ممتاز يعني هذا يعني ما
البودكاست ليس ثقافيا مثقفين يجب انهم
يطلعون من السالفه هذه ما يطلعون عادي
يتكون يسوون عادي بس انه المفترض ان
بودكاست يعني خطا انفنجان اعلى برنامج ترى
يعني خطا يعني ما عندي مشكله انا ودي انه
يصير ممتاز وكده يعني ترى بياخذون هذه
[ضحك]
مواضيع حساسه ونقعد نتناقش وهذا
الاصل في البودكاست
صليل تلقى بودكاست كذا محتوى مرتب ومعد
وكذا انت مكمل يشتغلون الفريق فنجان قعدت
اعدهم امس اتوقع مع فريق
13 تقريبا يعني مباشر غير مباشر
بينما اغلب البودكاست برا اللي كذا تتصدر
القوائم لا تلقى سواليف ناس كذا جالسه
تسولف ما عندهم ذاك الاعداد الضخم هم
يدخلون يسولفون وخلاص
فهذا التاثير كذا فنجان حدد شكل البودكاست
في السعوديه
محليا ولا حتى عربيا يعني احس انه فنجان
وثمانيه يعني جالسه تلعب على مستوى
العالمي يعني ايش رايك في التصريحة ترى
ارقام وكل شيء يعني يعني احنا اعلم انك
يمكن
ظهر ترتيبه العالمي عادي مرات يوصل في
افضل خمسه وعشر البرامج
فصول ثمانيه ينافس ينافس كل كل الصحف كل
يعني فعلا والجوده انها تنافس كل العالم
وهذا الهدف اصلا من ثمانيه كلها فعشان كذا
نرفع مو بصحيح يعني صدق البودكاست عادي
يتحمل انه يكون كل شيء
بس ما يمنع انك تكون ممتاز فاحنا نبغى
نصير من افضل من ينتج محتوى على العالم
كله فانت ما عندك مشكله في البودكا فهذا
احنا نرفع المعيار لهذه الغايه انه احنا
سعوديين ولا عرب نقدر نصنع محتوى ينافس
العالم كله فاذا احنا جالسين نرفع المعيار
شويه كذا فوق بس بس انه عادي لو كان
سواليف
الاصل يكون فيه يعني
فارس نام معي صوتهم
[موسيقى]
مره
في واحد غريب كان ينام اوباما يعني طبقات
غريبه كيف تنام عليه يعني مره يعني خطا
عنده ارق بس هذاك
اللي حق النوم يا الله يا الله يا الله
كيف انه يجيب النوم والله اني سمعت
عموما عادي بس ما ادري
قمت من النوم صحيت مشيت والله انا امشي
يعني
[موسيقى]
الناس ينامون فتكمل الحلقات تشتغل في
القصد البودكاست كل شيء
التلفزيون والصحافه القديمه والاعلام اللي
الناس تعرفه يعجبني يطلع من مخ كل سعودي
وكل عربي انت
انس بوخش سرد كلهم صح تختلف الطبقات تختلف
الناس تصور ناس ما تصور ناس تسجلنا صوت
ناس جوده عاليه ناس بجوده رديئه ناس
سماعاتهم سماعات الايفون ناس
كلهم صح وخطا انه يصير كذا انه
المفروض
نرفع هذا المعيار ليش ما نسكاس حق سهله
والله يعني احس انه هو يعني يمكن دعمنا
حنا اللي قاعدين نقود السوق فالفون
فكره في 80 يحكمها الرؤيه التحريريه فهذا
اللي احيانا يسبب الاشكال
وين تبغى تروح يعني انت لازم انها كلها
تتصق مع رؤيتك التحريريه في كل برامجك
يعني وانت تبي تروح فاحنا عندنا ذيل الهدف
فهذه اللي يخلينا دائما ما نعدل برامجنا
قليله الناس اللي تطلب انه يبغون ينضمون
مثلا ثمانيه ولا يعني مره قليلين فماره
يعني يقعد الواحد معنا فتره طويله
او حتى برنامجنا يمكن سته شهور سبع شهور
سنه يمكن ما تطلع منها فخلاص نقفل
البرنامج بعد سنه من البحث فبس انه الهاتف
انه نوصل
الاليه تناسب رؤيتنا التحريريه وين نبغى
نروح سنتين ثلاثه اربعه بس طيب هذا كله
على نايف حمدان
ايوه
مر عليهم
اذا اقتنع ابد والله اني ارسلت له ايميلات
ارسلت وكلمته وكلمته عن طريق اصدقاء
وكلمته يعني ما صرت بكل مكان بس يعني يعني
يمتنع وقد يعني حق نبد الله مدافر
يعني وهو برضو يعني عزيز وغالي والله بس
يعني
يقول اني طلعت يعني دائما انا يزعجني طبعا
اي احد يقول ان ما عندي شيء اقوله اعرف
انه هو اللي عنده شيء يقوله فهو يقول
بس بحاول فيه
خلص يخلص الاداره
خاصه الطريق شكلها
[ضحك]
بس العداد في الراس مو في القرطاس
عبدالله عبد الله مجيفر ابد لو جاء بيكون
يعني بس يعني هو تنسيق يعني طيب الدحيح
والله الدحيح يعني صديقه عزيز
وبالعكس والله بس يعني هم يحب لقاءات يعني
ما يحب لقاءات نهائيه نهائيا نهائيا
واتوقع انك لو تبحث اللقاءات تذكر
مع ذلك يعني كذا
بالمحاصره حاولت معاه وقلت خلنا نجرب
وسجلنا والله حلقه يمكن قبل سنه ونص سنه
موضوع مهم حلو يعني
واكيد انه يعني
افضل ما يتكلم عنه بس عاد يعني بعد
التجربه ما يعني
قال اني شفت انا
[موسيقى]
ارتحترون
يوم الاحد ما في حلقه اعرف انه وارد بارد
انا عندي تحكم كامل
[ضحك]
يعني ترى احنا كم نسبتها صعب جدا لما
نطلعها مره صعب يعني هو احيانا وش اللي
يصير انك ما اطلعها ان المحتوى دي
لان الناس بس انها تجيك والله هنا
التحديات اخلاقيه لا تنتهي ليش انك انت
لما تنشر الناس تثق في انك يعني
ساعه ساعتين ثلاث ساعات يسمع حلقتك فانت
اخذت منه ثلاث ساعات
يصير
انا وثقت فيك انك تعطيني محتوى جيد يا اخي
اذا محتوى انت تدري انه جيد ليش تنشره
يعني بضيع وقتي فهو بيعرف بعد ساعه مثلا
ولا نص ساعه ان الحلقه حلوه
فعندك الحين علاقتك مع الجمهور بدك تضبط
هذه بس المشكله احيانا لما تطلع الحلقه
ليه السبب ممكن اكون انا السبب اني ما
قدرت اخلي الضيف يطلع
جيد صدق يعني انه ما طلعت المهم لاي سبب
مما طلع المحتوى زين
يا اخي عندك مشكله اخلاقيا طيف ترى من
اليوم اللي قبله وهو شايل يعني
مره هامه الحلقه جلس يحضر لها
بعدين جاء واعطاك ساعتين او ثلاث ساعات من
وقته
يعني اقلل احترام انك تنشرها يعني
وخصوصا انهم ما احد ما نعطي فلوس لاحد ولا
فهو يجي كرمه منه يعني
فيعني ابسط انك تنشرها بس يصير انك ما
تنشرون نحاول يعني ما صارت القليل مره ترى
ونحاول انه نقول لهم يعني انه باتفاق
ونشرح له
واذا كان الهدف مشترك ترى يعني انت طلعت
زين يعني انك تطلع بافضل شكل فاذا حلوه
ترى لان بالنهايه هي بالنسبه لسمانه هي
حلقه من مئات حلقات بس بالنسبه لحلقه يمكن
حلقه ثلاث حلقات من اصل ثقاتهم طيب العكس
وفي حلقات ممكن ما تنشر
في ضيوف تلقاه يطلع ثلاث مرات اربع مرات
الفكره لاننا في محتوى يطلع ثلاث حلقات
ورا بعض ابدا يعني مفترض ما في معيار يحدد
اي احد في معيار في تكرار الضيوف ولا لانه
الموضوع عندي الضيف يعني في موضوع نبغى
نتكلم عنه هو عنده ضيف الفلاني يعني او
الضيف اعتقد انه يعرف يتكلم عنه بشكل جيد
فما تشوف التكرار مشكله يعني اذا الضيف
يعني اذا بتكرر السالفه وبتكرر نفس
الاسئله وبتكرر هذه تصير مشكله
فاذا الضيف قادر على انه يعطيك محتوى
ممتاز ابدا كررها 15 مره ما في خطا يعني
مين اللي يقول والله انا ابغى افهم مين
هذا اللي يقول ما تكرر
الان نسال سؤال الجمهور الكبير
احط لكم اسئله الجمهور في النشره
هل بتكرر تجربه ياسر الحزيمي
[موسيقى]
ياسر يعني
بكل حالاتها فيها حاله فريده غريبه غير
قابل قياس
وغير قبل التكرار
فترى يعني
ما هي خطه ما هي حلقه متوقعه انها تصير
كذا ترى ابدا ابدا
الثلاثاء الثلاثاء انه تكفى
ترى اسمي ياسر مدري شلون جاء يعني صدق صدق
حاولنا ندور
اني انا حاطه يعني احيانا يعني اقدر اطلع
لك عندي ملاحظات
ان فلان يعني كذا انا جالس في جلسه فلان
واكتب اسمه واحيانا انسى يعني بس اني
اسجلهم فداك اليوم ذاك الاسبوع يعني
ففتحت جلسه ادور في المذكرات عندي ولقيت
ياسر حزيمي
يعني ما يعني بس يعني يعني اعرف الموضوع
ترى ما اعرف
ما في اي هدف ما ادري يعني مو هدف ان حلقه
يارب تكون تنتشر ابدا ابدا
صفر في المئه ما هو اصلا اصلا مو معيار
عندنا ثمانيه كلها اذا عندك سؤال جيد
عليها
[ضحك]
حزيمي
انا ما عندنا حلقه
بحثت في الاسماء اعطيتها ايمن
يبدون فيه حلقه جديده وهي كانت عن تربيه
الاطفال
تربويه ترى يعني حتى يعني هذا اللي في
بالي ان اللي قال لي عليها في جلسه ما قال
لي ترى في التربيه جيد تربيه اطفال حتى
والله
نسجلها قريب
يخطر في بالي انه نسوي حلقه عن تربيه
الابناء الحلقه
الجنسيه للابناء
التربيه التربيه بعيد عن التربيه الجنسيه
فقلت له حلقه عند الموضوع قال لي اسمع
خلنا بعد التربيه خلنا نشوف حلقه على
العلاقات انا في كتاب بسوي قريب بيطلع بعد
ما ادري كم علاقات ممتاز
عبد الرحمن
كان بياكد لي اللي أقلي اسمع ما ادري
والله يمديني اسجل معك يوم الاربعاء ولا
كان راغبنا بعيده بعدين قال له انه ترى
والله فعلا متورطين فتكفى
يعني بس عشان ننقل الاسبوع الجاي
وقال ابشر يعني دائما انكم تردين
في الرياض انه جاي من مجموعه من المجمعه
فجاء من المجمع كذا بعد يومين اظن سجلنا
احنا خميس كلمته اثنين اثنين او ثلاثه او
الخميس سجلنا الخميس
[موسيقى]
يعني حتى الاعداد يعني حتى العداد مسويناك
حتى على استعجال وطلع مو بافضل شيء بعدين
[ضحك]
افضل شيء يعني حتى رجعنا
شوي
وسجلنا يعني حتى اعاده تطبيق كانت قبل
يعني قبل حلقه مواجد حتى
اسئله معينه مدري ايش سجلت معه كنت اسولف
محفوظ تقول اسمع حطها مليونيه
قال لي خلال كم قلت خلال ثمانيه شهور اي
حلقه انا بدفع اعلانات بخليها مليونين
يعني مليونين مليون يعني
اظن انها حلقه العلاقات حسي ان الناس تخلف
علاقات
اوكي مليون بس بعد ثمانيه شهور
فما حد يعني ما في اي تصور على انها بتصير
بهذه الارقام ابدا يوم سمعتها بعد التسجيل
هو هذا
العداد
بس اختيار الشخص في الموضوع يعني انت مطوع
يتكلم عن العلاقات ما جبت والله اخصائي
نفسي ما جبت
يطلع معك
اقصد انه في ناس كثير يعني مو كثير بس
بمقياس الحلقه دي يعني كل شيء كثير
كانت تتكلم انه طبعا كذا في البدايه كل
الناس تمدح بعدين فجاه جت موجه لك انت هذا
اصلا كلام انشائي وانتم جايبين لنا واحد
مطوع ينظر علينا وانتم ما ادري ايش
يعني اذا الحلقه تفيد الناس تفيد الناس
فهذا واحد بس اثنين انه ما يمنع انه يكون
مطوع عنده قصه ومطوع جيت في العلاقات عنده
موضوع فهو لها عشر سنين يتكلم في العلاقات
وهذه المواضيع ولا يمنع يكون دكتور في
الفيزياء ولا مطوع
زائدا احس ان هذا الاعتراض اللي كان حتى
هذا النقاش كان يصير في المكتب انها انها
وش التخصص اللي قاعد يتناول موضوع
العلاقات وش التخصص بالضبط يعني فهمت علي
اساس اني بختار وشو الصحه النفسيه زين وش
درس عشان يصرف العلاقات هل في اي وش
المنهج اللي اخذته انت
المواضيع
المواضيع الانسانيه غالبا تتداخل في هذه
الاشياء فاقدر اكون متخصص مدري هندسه
كيمياء في هندسه كيمياء في هندسه
فمثلا انا متخصص مثلا الغذاء وما عجبتهم
بعد ترى يعني دكتوراه في كيمياء تختلف
معاه بكيفك بس
جايبين واحد
يتكلم
في المجال الانساني والمواضيع اللي ما هي
في علم التجريبي اللي قابل انك تحكمه
بالضبط واضح انه مجال الدخول فيها اكبر من
غيره يعني انت انا تركي اي احد يقدر يدخل
فيها يقدر يدخل فيها بس انها يعني
لولا انه ياسر عنده هذا القدر من
المحتوى اللي حاطه في العلاقات ما كان
اختي في موضوع العلاقات فهذه النقطه احس
انها عندك عشر سنوات يعني لما كنت ترجع
لمقاطعه عشان اشوف الاعداد عشر سنوات فهمت
فاذا انت بعد عشر سنوات ما قدرت تطلع لي
كلام متماسك فهمت زين مين اختار عشان
يسولف
كل اللي كانت يعلقون الناس اللي ما كان
يعرف
ياسر قبل انه له عشر سنوات بغض النظر له
صفر سنوات
وبعدين
واحد يقطعها صفر سنوات يقول
الصفر ما تجمع
[ضحك]
يعني
عن اي حاجه مع اي احد
وش المواضيع اللي تحبها دمك تقول
يعني في المواضيع اللي تؤثر في الناس انا
احس ان هذه المواضيع يعني اللي لها اثر
مباشر يعني او تلمس الانسان مباشره اليوم
يعني مواضيع الفلسفيه هذه ما يعني شوي شوي
تركني بس يعني مثلا كيف تصير مثلا كيف
علاقات كثيره يعني اشياء سمعتها اقدر
اطبقها على حياتي اليوم
كيف اتخذ قرارات افضل
كيف
استثمر فلوسي افضل كيف اكون انا انسان
احسن كيف اختار تخصص أفطر كيف اطور نفسي
مهنيا ولا كيف اطور نفسي ما ادري شلون ايش
الاشياء تساعدني اني اجرب تجارب احس لما
يسمع لي الواحد تجربه كذا في
مثلا زي مريم السلطان حلقه انها تنط بركان
وانها تسافر فهذه تجي اكثر من حاجه انها
بنت تروح تجيب المغامرات انا مدري كيف
فعادي ان الواحد يقدر يسوي تجارب فريده
وحلوه ممكن تجرب لما يروح ابراهيم سرحان
يقول لك انا سافرت صيني واني حتى كل اللي
رحت انا رحت يمكن سبع مدن وما خلصت ما
اعتبر نفسي رحت الصين
العالم اكبر يعني بتروح فجاه تبغى تجرب
تجارب جديده تاثر عليك على طول مباشره
الموضوع اللي ما تحسن برايك وفي المواضيع
اللي برضو حلوه بس انها تؤثر في
من انت احسنه حلو انه يعلمك كيف بديت
فسوينا حلقات مثلا عن الدور السعودي
الثاني الدوري السعودي الثالثه
عن الخليج نشات الخليج باكثر من جانب من
جانب الاقتصادي من الجانب التاريخي
السياسي مثلا عن عسير وهكذا يعني السنه
مره مهمه في فهم كيف نشات انت منهم اجدادك
ايش كانت يعني يقول لك لماذا حاضر فحس انه
فهم تراثك مره مهمه وتاريخك
والسياسه انك تفهم الاشياء حولك بهذه
الطريقه تخليك تطمئن الناس تهتم للسياسه
مره او حتى الاقتصادي كذا تصير الاشياء
هذه انت تتفاعل مع الاقتصاد بشكل يومي لا
يمكن واحد يقول انا ما احب السياسه كذاب
واقتصاد انت وظيفتك يعني احسنت تفهم
فكل شيء لها علاقه بالاقتصاد بشكل او باخر
ونحاول انها تكون فعلا حقيقيه يعني مثلا
زي
مثلا توطين ولا
يعني الاشياء اللي لها علاقه يعني بالناس
وما تكون شعبويه يعني
انا بعطي الفكره اللي من خلالها تقدر تفهم
العالم من حولك فهذه حلقاتها مرت تعجبني
في حلقات اللي ما قدرت اتحملها مو قدرت
تعملها اني ما
مو مره مو اهتمامي يعني الادبيه يعني بحته
ما
يعني حاولت والله بس ما اقدر افتح سالفه
كامله لمده ساعه وساعتين عن الف ليله
وليله ما يعني ما اعرف ايش اقول بالله
عليك
ما ادري عادي اني اقدر اسوي حلقه ليش تكتب
كيف تكتب كيف الواحد يكتب كيف يعني في
الناس تعلم كيف الكتابه ولا كيف تقرا
الناس عندهم كيف القراءه بس ما اقدر يعني
افتح سالفه كامله عن
نقوداتها الف مو جوي يعني في بودكاست
ثانيه
انا ارتبك من هذه الحلقات ومع ذلك تلقاها
حلقه في كل خمسين حلقه يعني محاوله فيني
اتحدى نفسي والقاها وممكن تطرف جانب ثاني
فمثلا تكون حلقه عن
حلقه البوق الحلقات اللي ما انتشرت انتشرت
حلقه رائعه والله بس انها رهيبه مره مره
حلوه يعني رائعه رائعه رائعه وما ادري ليش
منتشرت يعني لاني ما اعرف
بس التسويق طيب يلا
فالبوق حلقه رائعه وكان فيها ادب من
بدايتها الى نهايتها يعني ويمكن ما خلاها
حلوه الا هذا الحضور الادب فيها الشعر بس
يجيك في فكره
الناس في فكره فهمك يعني ما بس اني اتكلم
عنها وهو طيب حدثني عن البيت هذا مش
المناسبه حقت القصيده
ما بتجي حلوه ما اعرف ما اعرف ما اعرف
والله يعني مره مره يعني خارج رغبتي وخارج
احسن يعني الواحد يحلوني
اصلا لما تكون مؤنثنه اكثر مخلي حلقه
البوق احلى هو انها كانت حاضره في سياق
مرتبط فيك
اتكلم عن علاقه العربي بالحيوان ومدري ايش
الفطريه بالمجمل فانت قاعد تاخذها من
البدايه علاقه عرب الحيوان في الماضي
وبعدين لا شعورين انت تدخل في الادب
والابيات اللي قالت فيها فتصرت تبدا
تفهمها في سياق اكبر هي ما جاءت لذاته هي
جاءت لي فكره اعم منها
يحضر لك اي شيء ادبي
[ضحك]
يعني هو اهتمام عادي يقدر يسوي
مره كان يقنعني بضيف
يقول لي انا بجيب يعني
وانا اقول له والله اني احس انه عنده
جمهور فعلا بس يعني ما ادري كيف اتكلم
يعني مره صعب يعني اخاف اني
ماني مستحضر
يعني النقاشات والتاريخ حق الفكر في
السياقات
فقلت على الاقل يبغى لي شهر عشان يجلس
ادخل في السياق هذا فافهم
بيتكلم عن ايش يعني
كلش لا لا لا الاسبوع الجاي وانا بكون
اسوي كذا
[ضحك]
ارسل لي الاعداد عشان اذا اعجبني يعني
فكره التوجه وكذا
خلني اقتنع عشان نسجل عشان اكلم
قال لي تمام انا عندي
ارسل لك العداد
[ضحك]
اول شيء
حتى الاعدادات يا اخي
هو بيقول لك وعليكم السلام
تسال عنك كيف حالك وعلومك طيب شو اخبارك
[موسيقى]
الحياه حلوه وكذا هذي عشر دقايق هذي عشر
دقايق خلصنا عشر دقائق باقي عندك 40 دقيقه
كله ايش رايك في الشعر الحديث
هذه اكيد انها عشر دقايق
قول له طيب وش رايك في الحداثه
[موسيقى]
اسئله من حديث الضيف مو من الاسئله اللي
مكتوبه عندك عندي
[ضحك]
تعاونها يعني يعني
يا الله يا الله يعني
طيب
بدينا نسولف عن حلقه البوق اللي ما انتشرت
في حلقه الحسيمه اللي انتشرت
هل الانتشار اصلا عيار يعني والله هذه
حلقه موضوع كويس ضيف كويس خلصنا تمام بس
يا اخي ذا الموضوع ما احد يهتم والله ولا
موضوع كذا متخصص ما احد بيعطيك ولا انه
هذه الحلقه ما راح تجيب ارقام فخلاص
الحلقه هذي من بدايتها ومن يوم عرفنا مثلا
حلقه البوقيه عن الحياه الفطريه فمن اقول
لك انت بتقفل مخك على طول يعني
في غير مهمه بس انه ندري انه مهمه والله
يعني يوم تسمع الحلقه يا اخي كميه معلومات
فيها رائعه فلهذا المعلومات والاثر
هو اللي يهمني لما تسمعها تدري ليش ليش
انا ابغى اعيد الحياه الفطريه في السعوديه
ليش مهمه ليش مهمه يعني مثلا الرجل اشتغل
على انه يعيد المهى العربي
وصار يعني عنده يعني من وصلت الى انه
متظاهر يعني
الامور المتحده تصنفها لانها خلاص منقرضه
الى ان الحين في مرحله صارت متقدمه صار
عندنا 1500
وينقرض من الوجود
والان رجعت النمر العربي طيب ليش السعوديه
تهتم يعني ما يعني ليش المحميات موجوده
الان يبغى يسوي المحميات من شمال السعوديه
لجنوب السعوديه متصله مع بعض ليش انت تبغى
ترجعها بهذا الاتصال لانك انت اذا حطيتش
بوك اذا حطيت هذه انت فقدت الحياه الفطريه
ليش انها يعني طيب ليش القرود منتشره
بزياده لان الحياه الفطريه تخربطت بس
الجراج يطلع لان الحياه الفطريه تخربطت
فانت لما ترجع كل شيء الى طبيعه اللي
خلقها عليه كل شيء يرجع زي ما كان تلقى في
حيوانات تاكل حيوانات ما تجيك هذه للمدينه
فجاه المدينه يكثر الصراصير والجراد
والمدري ايش لاختلال الحياه الفطريه
فتلقى يا الله طيب وكيف كانوا العرب
حلقه حلقه
انه خلق يعني خلق هذا انها صارت امتع يعني
هو الموضوع جاف بحد ذاته صدق جاف فحسي ان
المحطه الابيات صارت
حلقه عسير يعني حلقه يعني فيها اهتمام
شخصي
طبيعي انت من اهل المنطقه هو كان يقول
بشرح المناطق كلها ههه فجاه
[ضحك]
يعني حلقه عسير
يعني ما هو متوقع
يعني كم عدد اهل عسير فهو عدد محدود وكم
المهتمين منهم محدود وكمل مهتمه خارج اسير
انا اسير يعني واضح ان حلقه تسادف شريحه
سريه مره يعني مره
علي تحال
برطور رجل قادم من يعني ابها الى هنا لاجل
الحلقه يعني حلقه كانت مكلفه من كل
النواحي لانتاجه واحنا عارفينها ما لها
علاقه بالانتشار يعني لان احنا نبغى الهدف
الاساسي اللي هو الاثر وصناعه
الحساب
يعني سبحان الله انتشارها مو طبيعي النيه
سبحان الله
صدق انعكاس الارقام يعني دلاله على انه مس
الناس فصرت تقدر تتخيل انك لو سويت عن
مناطق ثانيه وحسنت اختيار الضيف واحسنت
الاعداد فيها لانه بالضروره بينعكس عليها
عساك على القوه نترقب حلقه القصيم انتم
اهلها ابدا اقترحوا
يا ابوي
ارسل لك فويس نوت هذا اللي اقدر عليه
طيب اذا الانتشار ما هم معيار تاثير حلو
ليش العناوين الفتره الاخيره انا احس اني
قاعد كذا اطلق على نفسي
بس انا ينفع يعني ليس العناوين انهم تحس
انها لغرض الضغط
لانه تجي تشوف اليوتيوب اللي عنوان الحلقه
ايش ذا العنوان يعني احس انه وحتى يمكن مو
بس في فنجاني يمكن حتى برامج ثانيه الناس
صارت تقول تغيرتوا الحلقات صايره العناوين
كذا تستهدف اني اجي اضغط يعني فيها اثاره
عندي مشكله فيها مره صدق يتهاوش معكم يا
فريق التسويق واجد يلا تفضل يعني احس انه
[ضحك]
يعني انا احس انه في مساحه ما بين اني انا
اجذب الناس واصيدهم مره واني ابقي على قدر
عالي من
المصداقيه انا اظنها لما انت تحط هذا
العناوين اظن انها في مصداقيه تنخفض في
قدر منها ينخفض افهم لما يكون انا ما عندي
المحتوى ما كان مره زين فانا بسيد طرف
سالفه بس عشان اختار عنوان زي الناس فهمت
علي فانا احس ان هذي بالذات لما صرت تاثر
على الضيوف
لان انا اظن انها تاثر على على اشوف انا
ظنه تاثر على شغلات واجد على الضيف احيانا
اذا كان الموضوع يعني
يستفزيت الناس وصاروا عادي يهدمون ثمانيه
تمام عادي بالنسبه لي انا اللي باكلها بس
بالنسبه لي انا ككيان يهاجم ما في مشكله
بس احس ان المشكله لما يهاجم شخص الضيف
انا امشي معك من بدايه الحلقه من بدايه
التواصل وابني لك فكره ان حنا اثنين
قاعدين فنجان قهوه ونجين نسولف وحبي انت
بس تطلع من الاستديو انا اجي اطعنك
بعنواني يقهر
فانا احس ان هذه كذا اللي تزعل
الجمهور يبدا يتكون اظن عندهم شعور انه
[ضحك]
يعني نوعا ما يكون فيه يعني لازم يكون في
اجابه له كان سؤال لازم يكون في اجابه
تدور على شيء ما تلاقي احيانا بالصريح بس
الحلقه كلها جاوبت هالسؤال يعني اوكي احس
اني اخونك شوي هنا
بس ما زلت ما كذبت عليك
الفكره انك تطلع يعني فكره العنوان في
العموم اني هذا الكلام ايش افضل شيء يعبر
عنه او الشيء اللي بيحفزك انك تتفرج عليه
يعني
بس انا انا
قعدت معك الحين سنه سنتين اظن انا انا
اعرف يمكن نقول بعد سنتين عليها بس اظن
اني بفقد
مصداقيتي
مصداقيتك عندي
اظن ان احنا رايحين هناك
اول اظن
اظن انه اول كانت العناوين جدا ادبيه
ادبيه تحس ان روايه فاكسر حتى يعني
الاعتبارات تسويقيه ما عاد تكون موجوده
لانك عميق ما كنت اختار قبل ما اجي
لا لا
كانت اد بيه جيت انا ضبطت شوي عرفنا
المشكله
بس لما يكون يعني ساعتين
قهرتني ودخلتني بالنهايه الاقيها فيما بعد
الحلقه عادي بس انت تكون طرف ليش طيب يا
اخي تسوي لي كذا يقهر الشعور يقهر فانا
اظن ان هذا
اول شيء انه احنا يعني انت في الاخير
العنوان هدفه جذب يعني التسويق للحلقه
فانت تبغى الحلقه هي ليست مجرد وهذا كلهم
الناس اللي تسويه في العالم حتى المنتج
الجيد الى يقدمه لك اذا ما حطيته في علبه
جيده ما قدمت لك بافضل شكل ممكن ما تشتري
هو جيد انت تقدم المنتج جيد يجيب انك تسوق
بالكامل جيد فالعنوان الصوره الغلاف
تغريدات مدري ايش يعني كل يعني الباقه
كامله تكون انيقه رائعه مميزه
جزء من هذه الالوان اذا حطيت العنوان تخيل
تحط العنوان ما هو الاقتصاد ما هو
الاقتصاد والله ما اضغط عليه حتى ولو مهتم
بس انت ممكن تعطيني المعلومه اللي تخليني
انا اضغط عليه نستفيد وتعلم وما كذبت عليه
معقول
مدري شو هل هل اليمن
اصل العرب هل اليمن اصل العرب وتدخل تلقى
الحلقه عن
باريس يعني تلعب علي وهذا بياثر على
احصائيات ويؤثر على المصداقيه بيؤثر اصلا
جوجل تعرف ان الناس تضغط لانها تطلع لكن
انا انا في الاخير عندي حل مدتها ساعتين
ثلاث ساعات واحنا رائعه
ثلاث ساعات انا ما ترى ما فيها موضوع يا
اما يكون فيها موضوع جامع في العلاقات
مثلا ولا زي حتى الرجوله يكون في موضوع
جامع
فمكان تلقى له جيد انك تحطه احيانا هي
مواضيع مختلفه فانت بتختار واحد من
مواضيعه ليش تكتب العنوان 60 مليون سالفه
فهمت خياراتك ترى عمليا الناس تسولف انا
عندي مشكله مع التنظير في الحقيقه انت
بتتورط انت ما يمكن انك تبغى تحطي عنوان
العنوان محدود بعدد كلمات محدده تبغى توصل
معلومه واضحه وما تبغى تكذب على الناس
تبغى تسوق منتجك
هذه المعادله طلع لك هذه فانا في ناس تزعل
اي بس احنا نكتب لا هل نبغى نكذب لا انت
تعرف انه لو كان العنوان خلينا نقول ما
نقول كذا بنقول مظلل حلو الناس تدخل وتطلع
هذا اصلا مضر بحد ذاته للحلقه انه معدل
المشاهده ينخفض فاقتراحات اليوتيوب او
اليوتيوب ما يقترح الحلقه احنا يمكن نتوقع
خمسين في الميه من مشاهدات القناه من
اقتراحات اليوتيوب
فانا كاني جالس ادخل للناس تدخل بس في نفس
الوقت اقلل معدل المشاهده فاخرب على نفسي
اصلا انا ما اقول
الناس زعلانه وانها بتفقد
لا او يشترك ههه
بس نخلي اللي في النشره يختارون العناوين
ومو بس كده الفصول فالفصول الحلقه تساعد
في انك توصل خلاص لا تتابع هذه روح
للمعلومه هذه تراني ما ابغاك
تدخلوا نسوي محتوى يجيب ارقام عرفنا كيف
نسوي
جد يعني
اقصد ما تطلع ليش ما تطلع وترى اللي
يزعلون ترى
لا لا
يعني مش العنوان المثالي
كذا اشياء الاضاءه نقطه الرئيسيتان ما بين
الحاضر والحداثه وتطور العصر القديم
واضح منهم مثقف
[ضحك]
وفي الاخير عشان كذا الندوات حقتهم ما
يحضروا الا 30 واحد ولا لا قيمه يعني رغم
انها محتواها قيم بس انك تروح تحطه اطار
ما ادري ايش تبي سم
يعني مره مره غريب
تطلع ان انا اقعد اقول لك ان المحتوى جيد
هو فهمت بس في هذا قدر القدر من خيبه احنا
قاعد اتكلم على محتوى جيد اصلا
[ضحك]
يسبب شعور قال وبالنسبه لتعليق واحد
يتضايق من ذا يسوى عندي والله يسوى عند
الدنيا
[ضحك]
يعني بالنسبه للصعيد الشخصي الصعيد الشخصي
لا لا صدق والله فانا احس ان هذا اشعر ان
هذا
[ضحك]
يقول رايلي سته شهور انا والتسويق وياك
وهذا هذا الراي
مشاكلنا داخل عشان كذا
ايمن مع انه والله انه يخترع والله اني
يضغط
[ضحك]
مسؤوله مسؤول التسويق عندنا نوره يعني ما
دربت احد انا اشارك فقط
[ضحك]
وقلت اشعر
خلص خلص
هل انت تستحوذ على اي واحد ينافسك يعني
تشوف بودكاست قاعد يطلع يجيب ارقام تعال
شيل كم تبغى
معك صحيح
يعني في كذا سلسله استحواذات سوالف
استقراض بعدين مربع بعدين بدري
كانها كلها صارت في اسبوع
وهمم
طيب بدينا مربع يعني قبل سبع شهور
والهدف صدق يعني ما يعني بالعكس يعني اي
محتوى
ما ادري ايش كنت برضو الاستحوا كانها خطير
يعني شر مطلق يعني انه كذا انك تاخذه تعال
لا تنافس كل البودكاست يعني
مربع بعد ثمانيه كيف صار فاذا الهدف يعني
اتذكر يعني طبعا يعني قال لي حاتم يعني
انه يعني كان يستشي وكذا احنا في النقاشات
هذه من الناس يقولون لا
ترى ممكن ياخذونك بس عشان يقفلونك
لسه ثمانيه موجوده اصلا هي اللي اثراء
المحتوى العربي وتقديم محتوى عربي رائع
مؤثر
فايا يكن هذا المكان ايا يكون المحتوى
احنا نبغاه يكون موجود ومستمر يمكن حاتم
لو كمل الحاله يمكن يمكن ما عاد يقدر يكمل
بس اذا انت في منظومه في الشركه
فتضمن هذه الاستمراريه واحنا مره يهمنا
الاستمراريه ونفس الشيء استقراض نفس الشيء
سوالف يعني ما بعد ثمانيه نحاول انه نطور
نحط فريق نشتغل معاهم يشتغلون معهم
يساعدونا تساعد كل منظومه باننا نرتقي
بالمحتوى اللي يقدمونه في كل المجالات
اللي احنا تعملها فاي محتوى احنا نهتم له
بنحاول يعني ما استطعنا اما انه اذا كان
انضمام مع ثمانيه
جزء منه
اتوقع اكثر كلمه سمعتك تقولها اشتراكات
انه انت تبغى انه قلتها حتى في اكثر من
مكان لانه ثمانيه هذا المحتوى قاعد
تشوفونه ترى لا تنبسطون في مره ترى بيصير
اشتراك بعدين بس لا لا عادي خلونا ينبسطون
فيه
[ضحك]
وليش انت تبغى يعني انت الحين جزء من اكبر
مجموعه
قد تعد من اكبر المجموعات الاعلاميه في
الشرق الاوسط في العالم واذا مو ابد لكن
من علاقه فيها
يعني علاقتنا بالمجموعه يعني ما العلاقه
بهذا الموضوع يعني ما لها علاقه اذا هي
كبيره فالله يوفقها لانها كبيره يعني انا
عارف بس قصدي كونك جزء من هذا الكيان
يساعدك باشكال كثيره متعدده انك تقدر تدير
مواردك وتنتج بشكل
بالمعايير اللي انت حاطها بدون ما تخلي
محتواك فلوس ما له علاقه ابدا ابدا
لانها شركه يعني مدرج اي فلوس تبغى تحطها
بيبان يعني خلينا نتاكد من هذا الكلام اذا
يطلع ولا لا بس
من وقت الاستحواذ اللي اعلن وبالقيمه اللي
اعلنت
بعدها ما عاد لا علاقه يعني انتهى الموضوع
فهم مو بكل كذا
يقدرون ما بيقصرون بس ما يقدرون يعني
قانونين
انا عارف
ان لعبتي تبسيط المعلومه ترانا ملك
الحوارات
[ضحك]
متى ما ادري يعني هي هي معادله صعبه
والناس احس انها انا ما احس ان الناس تزعل
والله صدق ان الناس تقول الناس بتزعل من
الشركات وانه هذا غير صحيح وزي كذا ما احس
واحس ان في بس تقدم تجربه مثاليه انت كل
ما تحتاجه انك تقدم مكتبه وماده تستحق
الدفع
فاذا عندك ما يسوغ للناس انها تدفع الفلوس
الناس تعطيك فلوسها يعني ما عندها مشكله
والناس تدعم مثل هذا يعني انا اعتقد انه
اليوم لو قلنا دعم حتى مو اشتراك ان الناس
بتدعم لان الناس تبغى مثل هذا المحتوى
تؤمن بهذه الافكار تؤمن بهذا يعني اهميه
اثراء المحتوى لكن احنا برضه ناسس يعني
جزء مني يقول انه نبغى نعيد للمحتوى يعني
الحياه ولكن ما يمكن ان يكون حي بدون فلوس
فاذا ما كان بفلوس
يعني لازم فلوس بس هل الفلوس تجيء اما من
الحكومات
او من احد عنده ايدولوجيه معينه
واحنا ما نبغى الثنتين يعني
من حكومات وعندنا تجربه تقدر تشوفها اول
ما تبدا الحكومات تبدا تشد حزام ولا تبطل
انها تدعم
تختفي
فما ودك انك تعتمد على عنصر غير المستدع
اثنين والثاني تموت بدك يعني ما يعني
فودك انه يكون يعني فعلا
مشروع تجاري لغرض التجاره فقط وكذا انت
تقدم زي ما الناس تقدم يعطيك قهوه يعطيك
قهوه جيده انت تدفع الفلوس وهي يوظف ناس
وضف ناس تسوي قهوه افضل تفتح فرع ثاني
وهكذا فاحنا نبغى نقدم محتوى جيد ناس
تفعله احنا نسوي محتوى افضل فيصير حتى
حركتنا مو مع المعلنين المعلنين جيدين ما
عندي مشكله بس اعتمادك على المعلن فانا
دائما اقول انه يعني المعلن ما هو
باساسي في مصادر الدخل الشركه ومهم انه
يكون كذا عشان ما يصير تاثير المعلن هو
بياثر على المحتوى فجاه تلقانا نهتم
للارقام
فالمعلم ممتاز حلو انك تتنوع مصادر الدخل
لكن المهم واللي ترى بيضبطنا لما يصير
الناس اللي تعطينا فلوس فيصير احنا نقدم
محتوى يحترمه اذا سحب فلوسها انا بانهار
فيصير انا اهتمام من محتوى يصير افضل انه
يهم الشريحه اللي جالسه تدفع وبكذا يصير
عندك محتوى ممتاز تضمن استدامه ممتازه
تخلق جيد تجيك شركات ثانيه احس ان هذا
الشكل الصحي والناس تدفع يعني مثلا كم عدد
المشتركينها 200 مليون مشترك يدفع
200 مليون مشترك يدفع شهريا عندك نتفليكس
230 و240 مليون مشترك
يعني بس هذولا محتوى ترفيهي
يدفع اشتراك
وانا اكره اكره اكره انك تجي تقول اوبس
العرب ما يدفعه انا هذه سالفه العرب
والغرب يعني هذه هي اللي تقهرني مره يعني
مو بصحيح العرب لم يقدم لهم محتوى جيد
عشان كذا هم اذكياء كفايه انهم يدفعون
المحتوى ههه
عشان تتفرج في الصندوق الاسود ما عندي
مشكله قدم محتوى جيد الناس تدفع الناس ما
بتتفرج حتى حتى ببلاش يعني ما عادي مره
يعني
بس فودي انا انا اؤمن بالحوافز أحس ان
الحوافز تاثر على الانسان سواء موظف ولا
اي انسان يعني الحوافز مره تؤثر فلما تعطي
مثلا جبال الموضه ان احيانا تحط عليه
مؤشرات اداء لهدف مثلا مالي فجاه ممكن يغش
ممكن يسوي اشياء كثيره لان يحقق الرقم هذا
فالحوافز مره مهمه او المؤشرات
المؤشرات والحوافز اللي على ثمانيه ما
تكون لغرض صناعه محتوى جيد والغرض الاساسي
لصناعه محتوى جيد هو ان كنت تقدم خدمه للي
يدفع لك فانا اذا معلن هو اللي يدفع لي
فانا بقدم له جيد ما يهمني انت يا انت
المشاهد فبقدم له المحتوى الجيد ما ادري
يعني زي ما يقول
شو اسمه بلال فضل فخذ
واحده يعني ما ادري يعني انا ناسي والله
بس انه يعني تسوي المحتوى هذا وتلقى انه
يجيب لك ارقام افضل وبنروح هناك ابد
والمعلوم ما عنده مشكله اهم شيء انك تجيب
لي مئات الملايين من المشاهدات والضغطات
انا راضي اذا هذا المعلم فاذا هذا الناس
اللي تبغاه
هذا اللي بيصير
لانك انت تخدم المعلم واذا تخدم الحكومه
واذا انت بتسوي محتوى اي شيء فانا اؤمن ان
العلاقه الصحيه واللي بتصنع محتوى جيد هي
علاقه مع المشترك مباشره
وانا اقول انه بس احنا ما
تجربتنا وقدمنا مكتبه جيده واذا قدم مكتبه
الناس بتدفع
وبتكون تجربه حلوه بس يعني حلو على جزئيه
نضج المكتبه اليوم
افترض عندكم فلوس يعني ما شاء الله
استوديو
اليوم
في مبادرات كثيره لدعم المحتوى فيه برامج
كثيره صناديق كثيره كلها متخصصه يعني صار
عنده الحكومه كذا هدف لدعم وتمكين المحتوى
العربي والمحتوى في السعوديه تحديدا انه
يكبر وكذا
لكن يعني اذا افترضنا انه هذه المبادرات
موجوده وثمانيه عندها مصادر داخل برضو
تساعدها انها تكبر ايش اللي يخليه ثمانيه
ما يعني اوكي فنجان كويس ليش ما في عشره
قناه الوثائقيات تنزل وثائقي كل شهر ليش
ما تنزل وثائقي كل يوم ايش اللي يمنع
ثمانيه انها تنمو كذا نمو
ضخم يعني احنا مو ضخم ترى مره يعني ماليا
يعني ما اقول نحن نخسر احنا في القوائم
خسرانه بس بس احنا يعني نمونا المالي
والايرادات اعلى بس احنا لي هدف النمو
نخسر فنخسر بالاختيار فعندنا نمو هائل
ماليه وعندنا نمو هائل في الاجتماعات
والمشاهدات يعني مشاهدات ثمانيه هذا العام
اكثر من مشاهدات ثمانيه في تاريخه كله
ممكن هذه السنه هذه السنه بس اللي ما خلصت
في السته شهور الست شهور لحالها اعلى من
ثمانيه في كل سنوات
عدد المتابعين اللي هذه السنه بس في ست
شهور
اعلى من ثمانيه في كل سنوات اللي قبلها
يعني
النمو في كل مكان بس احنا برضو نؤمن
بالجوده بس يعني هي اما سرعه واما جوده
يعني خيارين مره بسيط فاذا كان قصدي اول
منتجات ابد انت تبغى جوده سرعه يعني عادي
وهذي شركات في شركات تحب بسرعه في شركات
تحب الجوده
تصير سريع
عادي يعني لذا في سامسونج
طيب اذا انت تهتم بجوده معناته انك انت
تقتل مشاريع مره كثيره
فكيف تتعاملوا مع هذا يعني اذا جيت ثمانيه
تعلن عن منتج جديد او برنامج سواء بودكاست
ولا سلسله وثائقيه ولا
هل انتم تقتلون منتجات كثير في سبيل انكم
توصلون الجوده الطبيعيه يعني فانا عندنا
الابتكار قسم الابتكار ويصير فيه البرامج
يعني ممكن تدخل تلقى انه يعني في برامج
انتجنا كم حلقه منها
يعني
ما هي جيده كفايه
حلوه بس كفايه ما وصلنا للشكل المثالي وفي
حلقات برضو انتجنا كذا يمكن ثلاث اربع
حلقات وصلنا فعلا ما يضبط
فهذا مره مهم بالنسبه لنا
يعني فالابتكار مره بالنسبه لنا مهم يعني
ونجلس ندور ونحاول كيف نقدر نوصل الشكل
المثالي فتبقى مره احنا قليل يعني الاشياء
اللي نسويها ترى يعني عدد برامجنا تعتبر
اقل بينما احنا
شبكه البودكاست الاكثر انتشارا في العالم
العربي كله ومن اهم الشركات في البودكاست
في العالم كله
الا انه عدد البرامج قليله يعني
[موسيقى]
كذا يعني هي فلسفه يعني انك تنتج محتوى
وحتى ممكن ننتشر ويطلع معهم جيد ما يتفاعل
مع السوق بشكل جيد ونقفل ونلغيه يعني عادي
الوثائقيه يعني اللي يقهرني
يعني
زي لما نسوي
وسفر والتصوير وبعدين ينشر يقولون يا اخي
والله حلقه البودكاست هذه رائعه جدا
وثائقيات فيلم يعني مره يعني تقهر ههه امس
كنت ناظر احصائيات الناس ايش تكتب عن
ثمانيه اكثر كلمه انكتبت بودكاست ثمانيه
اصلا
والله تحديات ما في احد كامل حلو ههه
[ضحك]
ولا ايباد هذا
فعلا يعني
نظره الناس لانه وثائقي فالناس انت تسال
فيه والبودكاستات اللي عندنا اغلبها
حواريه فالناس كلها يعني يشبه عيال ثمانيه
اسئله كانوا الفريق يقولون انه اكثر
اقتراح يجينا ليش ما تنطقون السؤال لاني
انا اشبك ايوه اسمع الحلقه
انت لازم تتفرج برنامج مرئي
السؤال المهم خلاص يبي الناس
اسئله كثيره
روح
[ضحك]
ساعتين
كم باقي عندي نقطه بس خلاص
يعني انا اشتغلت في اماكن كثيره صراحه ولا
اقول لها يعني
[ضحك]
فالصدق اني جربت تجرب عمل مره كثيره جربت
التجارب بشركات صغيره جربت تجرب شركات
ضخمه شركات تمشي بالبصمه هذا وانت تكلمت
عنها
بس تجربه العمل ثمانيه كانت مختلفه
في هذه الامتيازات اللي انت قلتها بس في
المقابل فيه
ثقافه في طريقه اداره الشركه وفي طريقه
اداره حتى المدراء داخل الشركه كيف يعني
اذكر
واحد في اقتباس ستيف جوبز يقول افضل
الموظفين هو الموظف اللي يدير نفسه بنفسه
كيف ثمانيه وهذا شيء انا من اول يوم جيت
لاحظت انه كثير من الموظفين فعلا يدير
نفسه بنفسه ودوره المدير ليس انه يوزع
مهام ويفتح مهام للفريق قد ما انه هو يضع
كذا الاستراتيجيه والتوجه للقسم
وين بيروح وكذا
وتشوف الموظف هو يفتح المهمه ويشتغل عليها
ويقفلها ومديرها يمكن انت ما شافها ولا في
حتى سياسه الاعتماد فما في تعميدات في
الشركه انه لا مهمه اعتماد مدير التسويق
والاعتماد فريق ما في اعتمادات كيف تصنع
هذا هذه الثقافه داخل الشركه سواء عند
الموظف او حتى عند المدير اللي هو المدراء
عندهم حب التحكم مدير يعني
بتحكم في العالم كيف هذه الثقافه تصنع
داخل الشركات
يعني هي صعبه والله يعني ما ادري يعني ما
في واحد اثنين تقوله بس يعني انا احس انك
يعني جزء من ثقافه شركات تبنى بناء على
اللي جالس يطبق على اللي يكتب فاحنا
الاشياء احنا نطبقها لانه يعني بالفرضيات
والتجارب اللي جالسه تطبق واعظم نجربها
بعضها تنجح بس نوصل لشكل معين فما يمديك
تجي تقول
التمكين ولا انه ما في اعتمادات وبعدين
تلقين كل شويه فيه اعتماد من يمين واليسار
ولا كيف لازم انك تطبقها بالكامل ويجمعها
بعضها تجي سلبيات تجي اخطاء تجي وانت تدرك
هذه المشاكل
يعني
بس هو التطور مستمر يعني
فما في شكل محدد صدق عشان تضبط الثقافه
احسن الثقافه هي يعني
كيف اسوي لان الناس فيها اصدقاء يجون مثلا
ثمانيه ولا يكونون رؤساء شركه ثانيه ولا
عندهم تاثير شركه ثانيه فكيف تسوون
الثقافه كيف اقدر اسوي ثقافه
اسماء
ما هي شيء يكتب
هي هي اشياء اللي لا تشتر لان هي اشياء
كذا فعلا هي تفاصيل صغيره هي هي انك لما
تقول الاجازات مفتوحه ان المدير فعلا ياخذ
اجازه مو انك تقولها وما تاخذ اجازه بعدين
الموظف يستعين ياخذ اجازه فتصير السياسه
قيمه وبدينا اللي تقول العمل عن بعد
والمدير مداوم 24 ساعه
صح يعني الناس تستحي تقول ما في دوام في
الويكند شغال يعني احيانا السبت اكون
طفشان
ادخل بس العب كذا
واحيانا تردد يعني ما ودي اكتب
اللعب اللي الله يحرمنا منك
[ضحك]
بس
فتلقاها يعني مثلا ما في ما في بريد ما حد
يراسل بريد بين الموظفين فما في بريد
داخلي نهائيا
ما في اتصال يعني ما حد يتصل عليك على
جوالك نهائي ما في واتساب نهائيا
ما عندي رقم اتوقع
قريب يعني
ههه
[ضحك]
خايفه ادق عليه
واتساب
فما في تواصل يعني وهذه حقيقه يعني لما
نقول لك كل عملنا احنا يجب ان يكون فيس
كامب لانه يكون مكان ما في يعني
حلو ومريحه
مكان عشوائي هو منظم هو مهام هو اشياء ما
في دردشه
احنا كلنا سلاك مكان مزعج مرهق مرهق
ذهنيا ولا ماندي ولا
ثانيه معاه بس بس هذه المشاكل احس باسكان
مكان مريح
التنبيهات تقدر تتحكم فيها متى توصلك فانت
تحدد اني انا اشتغل من الظهر الى الساعه
مثلا الى المغرب هذا اللي انت اخترت
التوقيت اللي انت يناسبك
تنبيهات بس مثلا بمفترض انها تجي تنبيهات
تشتغل طول الوقت
فتخيل انه نقول بعدين نرجع لك واتساب وينك
يعني مره غلط وبس كان مكان يحفزك انك تكتب
فما فيها رسائل صوتيه ملاحظات صوتيه
بيخليك تكتب ليش تكتب لانك انت لما تكتب
يعني يخليك تفكر اكثر فما تجلس تكيس علينا
تعبر عن فكرتك خمس دقائق فبتكتب هاي اذا
كتبتها يخليك
توصف فكرتك بافضل شكل ممكن ولذا ما نسوي
اجتماعات فما في اجتماعات
واحس اي احد يعني الحين يشتغل في اي شركه
وخصوصا يعني شركه كبيره ولا الشركات
الحكوميه ولا حتى معكم في اجتماعات كثيره
واجتمعت هذه مرهقه والله ويكون مافيها عمل
ولا فيها يعني فعلا في اجتماعات ممكن تكون
رساله واتساب
وفي اجتماعات اللي ممكن في البريد واحيانا
لما تكتبها احيانا عادي انه نكتب كلنا
بدنا نجتمع عشان نقفل الموضوع بسرعه بس
انا كتبنا افكارنا
وتكون كذا على طول يعني فمره مهمه احس
طريقه العمل
في نقطه كمان
يعني غير
الاجتماعات
يعني هذه كلها تصنع ثقافه
فهي رحله عمل متواصله يعني سنوات المكتب
يعني الثقافه ان المكتب اتوقع اشيل
العشرين موظف وحنا 100
فاصلا ما في امكانيه ان الشركه فيزيائيا
لو تيجي تصفهم هنا ما تقدر تجيب فانت اصلا
مجبر حتى كشركه بعيد عن الموظف انك تروح
قهوه انك إيه انك خلاص
المكتب ما ياخذ كل الموظفين فانت خلاص روح
اشتغل في اي مكان تبغاه
نبدا الجمهور نبدا
هذا اللي تذكرتها الحلوه في ثمانيه
اشياء لا تشترى الحلقه كذا
تفاصيل تفاصيل اختلاف اشياء لا تشتغل
[ضحك]
تاخذ الفضل اللي يسوون
فيلم شركات
ابداعيه لشركات الخدمات انت تسوي تصور ولا
تخرج ولا تنتج الفيلم كامل ولا اي شيء وما
عدا احد يدرك
بس هنا في نسبه الفضل لاهله احس انها مهمه
فتلقى انه الناس
يعني كلهم رايي حتى فاحنا ما نشتغل مع
عملاء يعني عندنا الجزئين للخدمات بس هذا
الموضوع اخر وله المسار الثاني بس في
منتجاتنا انه تلقى المخرج هو اللي يحط
التصور والمنتج هو اللي يفكر في عميل ما
في عميل نفسك وانت جاستنتج هذه الاشياء
انت جالس تعبر عن افكارك واشياء اللي
تشوفها وتنتج الاعمال اللي انت بدك تسويها
بالطريقه اللي انت تشوفها مثاليه وتطور
بنفسك وتقدر تنتج اشياء فعلا ما كنت تقدر
تسويها الا في
في مكان زي كذا يعني
[موسيقى]
ايوه
هذا الغلاف والله
[ضحك]
فنجان القديم ليش وقف
اذاعه القران الكريم
[ضحك]
احب حلقه ابراهيم يوسف
مرة
لو كانت مره فنجان مره بتحولات لا تنتهي
هذيك فتره كنا نقول ماذا لو كان
انه نقدر نخليها كذا يعني
بالحلقه فما تصير بس حوار وانك تدخل
مداخلات انك تعيد بلوره الفكره اللي بتيجي
يعني
[ضحك]
لا يزال صح اننا بس يعني هو جزء من التطور
يعني لو ترجع الحلقات قديمه تلقاها مره
مختلفه بس يعني هو تطور طبيعي يعني وانت
ما ودك ترجع القديم صدقني بس يعني
ما ابغى ما ابغى بس بعد سنه
مستحيل تتحمل القديم بس ان الناس يمكن بس
ما حسون كثير بس انه افهم الفكره يعني
ونحاول نسويها يعني اغلب الضيوف زمان ممكن
يعني فترى حلقه مثلا اللي عجبتك يعني هي
حلقه
في حلقه ثانيه يعني ممكن تكون حتى طيب ليش
ما في نساء فنجان
اسمع فيني
يعني انا عندي فلسفه مو فلسفه فكره يعني
ولا في ثمانيه
يعني ما في يعني ما عندنا كود يعني النساء
فيما بين انهم يكونون كثيرين
وفيه ما بين انه
هم مثلا يرفضون يعني
ما في ما نقول ان احنا في احد ما نبغاه
يطلع طبعا
ورضا للضيوف عن فنجان اتوقع انه عالي لان
المعد بس
ما اقرا التقييمات
يعني بعضهم يجي يرسل بعد بعد الحلقه او
يصير يصير اكثر مره حتى يعني اظن ان رضاهم
مره علي ما قد جاء احد يتشكس صدق يعني عن
عن الحلقات ما كانت جيده وقاعدين نحاول
نخلي واظن انه حتى اللي بيتشكى يصعب علينا
يجي يكلمني مباشره فكانت وحده من الاشياء
اللي تخليه ياخذ راحته انه يعبر اللي هو
الرابط اللي بعد الحلقه فيصير يرسل له
الرابط يصير يقيم كل شيء يعني يقيم حتى من
كوب القهوه الين درجه حراره الغرفه الى
الاعداد الين حتى حوار عبد الرحمن نفسه كل
شيء يقيمه ياخذ راحته يصير يتعامل وهو مع
رابطه على اريح له مع
مع اهلك قلت تعال
شي غلط طال
اريح له انه يعبر بالمساوي اللي هو يشرب
فما يقدر يعني
خلاص
انا احس انه
الرضا فيه يعني رضاهم عالي واللي يصير
مو براضي صرت حاول نعرف ليش
اطيح بنفس المشكله اللي قلت اي درجه هو
بيعبر عن عدم
مبيعاتة ستين بالمئه اكيد بيرضى ونص يعني
بس انه في ناس ما عندهم هذي فهمت ما عندهم
يطلع يضحي
بحسابه تويتر
في احد كذا اللي ما عنده منتجات فهو بيضحي
في وجودها الرقمي
يسبونه
ان الناس تهاجمه ومرتاح دائما في يعني
ممكن يقدم محتوى دائم بس انه متعود على
هدوء دائره معينه يتابعونا في النقاش يكون
يعني في دائرة مرتاح لها فجاه يتعرض الناس
جديده يعني
وخصوصا في تويتر يعني
على طول طب والسب فيكم يمكن مجرد الظهور
هو بالضروره انه بتلاقي ناس تعارضك
وتنتقدك فهذه على طول يعني اتخيل كل
الضيوف عندهم هذا التصور اصلا
لان مجرد ظهورك ترى غالبا في احد بيجي
طبيعي يختلف معك
انا الفنجان
مرتفع جدا
والله
رائع جدا
طب انا ما سالتني
[ضحك]
تمام تمام
وايش اللي يخلي الحلقات
يعني جد فتره اني كنت زعلان من التصوير
مثلا بس شكرا
[ضحك]
تقييمك عالي والله
حلو
بس بس يعني مثل هذا التفاصيل يعني
تخليه فنجان ويكون محتوى حلو يعني هذا
الهدف
قال لك
طيب في سؤالين قبل ننهي الحلقه
عمره ما يسوي
من سائل يسال هذه
عندكم اي سؤالين السؤال الاول
السؤال الثاني
جد هل يفرق البودكاست الصوتي والبودكاستري
اشوف في ناس تسمع يوتيوب بس ما تسمع صوتي
في ارقام ولا شي جمهوريه مختلفين
انه في ناس
الصوتيه في ناس تتفرج
وهذول مختلفين مو نفس الشريحه نادرا
احيانا يعني لان هذا يعني انه احيانا تكون
انه يسمع الحلقه بعدين يتحمس انه يعتقدم
في تفاعلات يعني هذه الحلقه اتوقع ان اللي
يسمع بيقول صدق ودي اشوف كيف جالسين
تفاعلات معينه في ضحك خلنا نشوف الحلقه دي
ضربت رقم قياسي تدري اكثر حلقه فيها اشخاص
هذا اول رقم بعدين ان شاء الله الرقم
بتجيب اللقاح فبتجيبه من جانب اجتماعي
جانب مثلا هو خلينا نجيب ضيوف من حلقه
م ترى طيب في الارقام طيب ما كملت فانا
اقول لهم احس ان اللي عندي
مشاعر غريبه يعني غير مبرره تجاه اللي
يسمعون
اكثر ولاء
ويهتمون المحتوى اكثر ما اعرف ما يهتمون
بمظهر صدق والله او انهم القديمين او
الناس اللي فعلا عارفه وش البودكاست يعني
فاهم ايش معناه اليوتيوب
طلع ممكن طلع لك كذا في وانت فاتح يوتيوب
بقيت اوكي
عناوينكم اوكي زي كذا
يعني ناس
فنجان
واليوتيوب في خوارزميات هذا يساعد ان
المشاهدات ترتفع وقد يقترح يعني بعض
الحلقات نسبه كبيره من المشاهدينها ما هم
مشتركين اصلا في القناه في المقابل
البودكاست ما في اي خوارزميه غالبا فانت
تدخل اذا ما انت متابع البرنامج او انك
تبحث عنه
الخوارزميه حقت التاريخ حتى نسبه الاستماع
في المستمعين اعلى كدقائق الاستماع
بس ما ادري عن الارقام يعني
معرفه الفرق بينهم يعني
الفرق بين العدد المستمعين فمن بدايه
السنه
تقريبا
[موسيقى]
يعتبرها
رقم طيب من بدايه السنه 144
يلا
124 مليون مشاهد هذا فقط قناه الاذاعه غير
قناه الوثاقيات مشاهدات قناه اذاعه ثمانيه
الاستماعات تقريبا 30 اذا ما
فانت تتكلم يعني عن 20% بس مثل ما قال عبد
الرحمن انه
جوده هذا الرقم تختلف في اليوتيوب لواحد
ضغط على الحلقه سمع خمس دقايق قفلها
عكس البودكاست غالبا نسب او دقائق
الاستماع فيه اعلى
جزيره خوارزميه انها هنا فيه الخوارزميه
هنا تساعدك تجيب المشاهدات كذا هنا لا
العامل البصري طبعا يعني يلعب دور كبير
واتوقع جزء منها العاده يعني انا من الناس
اللي افتحها في اليوتيوب واقفل الجوال
عشان كذا تاخذ شهاده الحين
عشان كذا رسمه مو عندي
شو بدك استشهدت يعني تعبان
ليش الصوتيه احد المرئيه اربعه
يعني رغبتي بان الناس يعني تهتم يعني
وتقديرا للناس اللي يسمعون صوتيين واللي
هم الاساسي يعني اول مئه حلقه كانت كلها
صوتيه فقط يعني
حدث لاحقا وكان يعني مره مهم يعني ما اغفل
اهميه
المرئي واحب اشوف احيانا حلقات مرئيه يعني
بس
[موسيقى]
في فنجان غير فنجان تشوف مشاهدات خمسين
واحد بدل لما يجي فنجان عادي مليون
جورج صريبه مثلا ايوه يعني
تقريبا سبعه مليون
مشاهده فقط غير الصوتي
فنتوقع يعني جزء منه اللي هو هذا العمل
ما قبل الحلقه في انك تختار موضوع معين
تعتقد جورج مثلا عنده
يعني يعني
اللي انتجه ثقافيا كبير انك تختار موضوع
معين مثلا لسالفه معينه عشان تعتقد انها
تم الناس يعني هذا الجزء ترى مره كبير فيه
التوفيق في في جوده يعني هذه اللي الناس
ما تفهمها يعني اللي تكلمنا عنها قبل شوي
اليه الحوار وطبيعه البرنامج كيف يخلي
جورج يكون مرتاح اكثر في الحلقه تصل للناس
افضل وكيف برضو انك تحاول انك تخلي
المحتوى يكون ممتاز وبرضو التسويق وغير
يعني هي منظومه كامله جلسه تسويه حلقات
جيده وبس فهذا اللي يخلي يعني
فنجان ما ادري ايش
ابد يلا ها هذا الضيف يطلع هنا ويطلع هنا
يعني ليش الناس تحبه هنا
[تصفيق]
[ضحك]
وكلهم
هراء والله ما افهمها يعني غير منطقي وغير
مقبول وغير مفهوم
يعني يجي يقول لك
انه الضيوف مشاهير فاصلا ما عرف عن فنجان
هو انه الضيوف غير يعني مدري وين
فاذا الضيوف مغمورين يقول لك نفوذ فاذا
الضيوف اصلا
[ضحك]
طيب مشهور نلف شوي بس ههه
ومن كل مكان في العالم اليوم مثلا
كل النسب
يعني ما عاد فيه يعني كلام ابد يعني
الحقائق موجوده قدامك والكلام تحطه في
الزباله
اللي هي ارائك ما يقال شيء بعد هذا الجمله
خلاص
والله شكرا طيب حنا بدينا نصور الساعه
عشره الحين الساعه كم ثنتين
فالحين ابيك تتفاجا زي جورج
اربع ساعات ههه
يا اخي لا هذاك المقطع قسما بالله اتفرج
ولا امل جدا
اذا ابغى اشوف قديش
مصر
فيها النكته تع
[ضحك]
والله يعني ما اثق فيهم والله ممكن ينزلون
اشياء غريبه يعني
[موسيقى]